Ich sehe, die ersten sind schon da, weil ihr wart schon da, bevor der Stream ongegangen ist, oder?
So lange ist der Stream noch gar nicht on.
Müsst vorher da gewesen sein.
Und da habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst, weil irgendwas spannend ist.
Ich überlege gerade, irgendwas irgendwie, wo man sagen würde, das hätte man mitbekommen müssen.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist jetzt seit Wochen schon diese ganze Twitter-Geschichte.
Naja, gut, was will man da großartig zu sagen, beziehungsweise, was soll man, juckt mich jetzt wenig.
Ansonsten war irgendwas, ich überlege gerade, war irgendwas Spannendes die Woche, ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe die Woche irgendwie in der News-Screenshot gesehen, dass die Gasspeicher in Deutschland jetzt bei 102% sind, wie auch immer das gehen soll.
Ich glaube, da muss man jemand nochmal was mit Prozenten erklären, aber okay.
Kann auch sein, dass das Fake war, es war nur ein Screenshot.
Aber es war die Woche, glaube ich, nichts Spannendes.
Also so, weltweit, ja.
Technik, technisch, weltweit, war glaube ich nichts Spannendes.
Trump wurde entsperrt, ernsthaft?
Ist jetzt, ist jetzt so, okay.
Mal gucken, hat er schon was getweetet?
Ne, ne.
Ich glaube, das ist, ist bei denen nicht noch mitten in der Nacht?
Ja, Sleepge.
Primulon, Dankeschön für den Sub, 34 Monate, Alter.
Es wird echt mal Zeit für neue Sub-Icons.
Krasser Scheiß, 34 Monate, das sind jetzt ja quasi fast drei Jahre.
So lange bin ich schon am Start, wirklich, ja.
Hab mich gar nicht dran erinnert.
Gut, ich habe am Anfang mit dem Fabian ab und zu noch ein bisschen BDO gestreamt und sowas.
Ist schon, ich glaube, ist noch länger, es ist noch länger her, wo ich mit Stream, Streamzone angefangen habe.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, man muss einfach anfangen.
Ja, 2017, das sind schon fünf Jahre, was ist denn?
Man muss einfach anfangen.
Just do it.
Ja.
Ne.
Das war, glaube ich, die Woche echt nix Spannendes.
Was macht dann?
Mal, mal gucken, ups.
Mal gucken, so, dass, ob es irgendwas Sinnvolles gibt, wenn wir gerade schon früh am Start sind.
Deals for you to improve, was, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Home Improvement, Tools und Home Improvement, Home Improvement ist auch ein geiles Wort.
Computer and Accessories.
Giftideen.
Ey, nicht Gift, nicht Giftidee, klingt ein bisschen verkehrt auf Deutsch.
Geschenkideen.
Okay, mal ganz schnell gucken, ob da irgendwas Sinnvolles dabei ist.
Wasch.
Oh, Moment mal, es gibt meinen Stuhl?
Ne.
Haha, hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Kackel.
Ja.
Das ist auch teurer geworden.
Leutnant Gizmo, moin.
Ja, das ist, äh, ganz schön teuer geworden, 2000 Euro.
So viel eigentlich hab ich bei weitem nicht bezahlt.
Okay, Crap, Crap, Crap.
Oh, ist das alles das Gleiche?
Guck mal, das ist alles das Gleiche, egal, was ich aufmache.
Leute, she baited.
Oh, das ist alles das Gleiche, egal, was ich aufmache.
Massive She Bait.
Angeblich unterschiedliche Kategorien, es ist alles das Gleiche.
She Baited von Bezos persönlich.
Deine Stromkosten steigen nächstes Jahr um 100 Prozent, meiner auch.
So, ist irgendwas... ist da irgendwas dabei?
Irgendwas, was mich sofort anschaut, wie das alles so aufwächst?
Oh, was ist das?
Okay.
spricht, sieht nicht so aus, nope, nope, nope, apple, okay, der Hüllen, geil, irgendwelche
komischen Handyhüllen, als interessiert mich das, ansonsten ist da nichts dabei, Handyhüllen,
na super, geil, super gespart, easy, nix, hat jemand von euch irgendwas gekauft, schon,
von diesem ganzen Prime Week, was eigentlich gar keine Week ist, und an dem Friday, der
eigentlich auch jeder andere Tag und Friday ist, 600 Euro, das waren die Uhren, yep, Clock,
bald kommt der Black Friday im Monat, manche machen das schon, du wirst lachen, manche
machen schon Black Friday im Monat, es ist, okay, es ist gar nichts dabei, wir gucken
jetzt eine Sache nochmal, wo manchmal ein bisschen was Gescheites dabei ist, es ist
Lightning Deal,
so, Rest ist aber alles Müll wahrscheinlich, aha, Socken, R-A-B-C, alles klar, Hosen,
Hosen, Powerbanks, irgendwelche WLAN Repeater, die keiner braucht, Schuhe, was auch immer
das ist, irgendwas zum Paddeln, Gürtel, Handschuhe, Jeans, Messer, Hosen, was auch immer, nur
wenn man das nicht nervös macht, dann ist das keine G beero, das ist ein bisschen
was, das ist ein bisschen wie ein V- manifold, das ist ein bisschen wie ein V- soit,
anzieht kriegt man also krasse muskeln alles klar aha buber messer schuhe eine güte es ist ja nur
krepp dabei hier erkenne ich nicht mal was das ist leute was soll das überhaupt sein ein kabel
was ist das ich erkenne es nicht was ist das für irgendwelche solarzellen okay es gibt ja gar nichts
leute gar nichts gut das macht er was man eigentlich die china die china chinesen was
man die china chinesen die euro kriegen wir jetzt wenn wir über fünf euro bestellen das
heißt ich bestelle über fünf euro sich bezahlt sich bestellt für sechs euro und dann kostet es
nur zwei euro gebetet geht nicht guck mal wisst ihr was ich bei aliexpress immer am besten findet
diese seite ja ohne scheiß für jemand der da noch nie drauf gewesen ist was ist moment was ist das
high iq usb stick der denkt doch die seite ist gern die sieht die sieht nur minimal weniger scam
ausgewischt das ist ja schiene typische china chinesen konstruktion alter ich war von der
idee her funktioniert das sicherlich ja was hat es mit android zu tun ein cent kostet was wie wo
steht das ach ja
hier und die seite ist auf russisch gekommen blieb ja da passt ja da passt ja nix hier an
dieser seite warum der android draufstehen habe ich auch noch nicht so genau verstanden das sieht
irgendwie falsch aus dieser anschluss oder das sieht irgendwie irgendwie falsch aus und ich
glaube nicht dass das sonderlich lange hält man sieht ja man klappt den irgendwie da vorne raus
wahrscheinlich guckt dass die neben irgendwelche knöpfe ja wahrscheinlich klappt man den ganz
k pesticides überhaupt dieser seite ist ja ich würde sagen ein 1.500 euro das jetzt hm materials
wie tabli es jetzt halt komplett aus der Cena
mache ich analyses
firewire braucht er noch leute firewire falls es noch irgendjemand kennt gibt eigentlich nix
mehr was man damit anschließt es ist einfach ein flugzeugträger warum auch immer auch richtig
richtig high IQ meta usb stick an usb stick wobei es ist ja gar kein usb stick aber es ist doch ein
usb stick weil es hat micro sd kartenreader hat man je firewire benutzt tatsächlich es gab einige
audio interfaces damals die firewire verwendet haben und das war relativ beliebt auf macs wie
oft wollen sie dieses bild jetzt eigentlich da noch rein machen und hier kriegt man sogar erklärt
wie es funktioniert ok anhand dieses bildes aha hier muss man hier muss man drauf drücken und dann
kommt das kommt das irgendwie raus sieht ganz schön fummelig aus attention ok man kann nicht
sd karte und usb mitmachen ok das leuchtet ein hier hätte man vielleicht den zeilenumbruch ein
bisschen schöner machen können oder war alles okay nicht schnelle verschiffen aber war alles
wie beschrieben
ich habe versucht es und es funktioniert gut danke empfehlen
alles obviously also man bekommt ja bei aliexpress wirklich allen möglichen blödsinn davon davon
professional phone cases store da der hat er usb adapter alles klar high quality aliexpress
werkzeug leute auf geht's auto werkzeug innen oh ja das sieht schon so aus wie der usb stick
aus, als überlebt es
nicht mehr als eine Anwendung
das ganze Zeug hier.
Das sieht auf dem Bild schon alles unglaublich
unglaublich billig aus, Alter.
Gut.
Moment. Was war denn das hier gerade?
Habt ihr die Masken gesehen? Was war denn das?
Jetzt ist es leider weg.
Was waren denn diese komischen Masken hier?
Äh, jetzt sieht man es nicht mehr.
Okay, China-Chinesen-Zeug. Genug.
Was auch immer.
Ja, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Alles klar. Gut. Jetzt müssen wir auch mal
Bescheid, was es bei AliExpress so Tolles gibt.
Abzocke an der Haustür.
Der Trick mit den wertlosen Büchern.
Will allen Ernstes
irgendjemand... Ist das der
neueste Enkeltrick, oder wie?
Ach, egal.
Meinem Opa...
Alter, das sieht schon so
überzogen billig aus, dass es eigentlich
nur Fake sein kann.
Meinem Opa wollten sie
auch mal damals Lederjacken
verkaufen an der Haustür, Alter.
Der hat sich dann auch noch scammen lassen.
Und nicht nur scammen lassen,
die haben ihn dann, glaube ich,
gefragt, ob sie irgendwie mal aufs Klo dürfen
oder so, und da hat die aufs Klo gelassen.
Da haben sie ihm auch noch das Geld aus der Schublade
im Bade... äh, nicht im Badezimmer,
im Schlafzimmer geklaut, Alter.
Und er hat nichts mitbekommen. Gut, vielleicht sogar
besser, als dass er nichts mitbekommen hat.
Wer weiß, vielleicht wären die noch aggressiv geworden.
Danach war die Anzeige raus.
Die Polizei wollte erst nichts machen, weil er
sie ja freiwillig reingelassen hat. Keckel.
Ja, als ist Stehlen okay
von Leuten, die man freiwillig ins Haus lässt.
Das war auch geil. Die haben ihm was
geklaut und die Polizei meinte ernsthaft
damals zu uns, die hatten keinen Bock, was zu machen, ne?
Meinte damals ernsthaft zu uns, ähm,
ja, der hätte die ja freiwillig reingelassen.
Also Leute, merken,
merke, merke, wenn euch jemand
freiwillig, genau, wenn euch
jemand freiwillig ins Haus lässt, dürft ihr
den beklauen. Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Das ist, äh, Polizei approved, ja?
Die hatten einfach nur keinen Bock, aber sie
mussten ja dann, letztendlich. Bleibt ja nichts
anderes übrig, wenn man da
hartnäckig ist. Aber
sie haben ja dann den Kram sogar gefunden, wieder.
Nach zwei, drei Wochen.
Ja, muss man.
Tänzer, deine Message wurde geblockt von Twitch,
weil dort ein, äh, nicht erlaubtes
Wort drin aufgetaucht ist.
Das geht nicht auf Twitch.
Direkt
Instant Shadowban
jetzt. Wie läuft deine Job so?
Ich hatte ein Vorstellungsgespräch am Montag.
Diesen Montag rufe ich da nochmal
an.
Und sag dann, ob ich will oder nicht will.
Die Horrorhäuser.
Naja, gibt's in Frankfurt
auch genug.
Guckt euch mal die Häuser in der Nidderstraße an.
Die sind bestimmt auch nicht weniger Horror.
Das ist so ein Ding
in Frankfurt, Leute. Wenn ihr jemals,
solltet ihr jemals nach Frankfurt fahren,
es gibt da so
eine Richtung, wo ihr nicht rausgehen
solltet. Zeig euch.
Ja.
Also, hier vorne,
hier vorne ist der Hauptbahnhof.
So.
Und wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof
rausgeht, äh,
Chat, wo ist der Button?
Wo ist der? Ah, hier. Da.
So. Wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof
rausgeht, das ist übrigens gar nicht der
Hauptbahnhof, das hier ist der Hauptbahnhof.
Hier, hier ist der Hauptbahnhof.
Wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof rausgeht, ja,
dann geht nicht den Weg hier oben.
Hier oben ist das ganze, ganze
Assi hier, Assimist.
Alles hier. Kannst vergessen. Also geht nicht hier rum,
sondern geht hier rum.
Ja. Kaiserstraße,
Münchnerstraße. Das ist zwar auch Assi
hier in der Ecke, aber nicht so
Assi wie hier, weil hier an dieser
Ecke, bin mir gar nicht sicher, hier,
Niederstraße
zu
Weserstraße, Moselstraße,
hier so an dieser Ecke,
hier überhaupt, da sind auch die ganzen, äh, diese
Drogen, äh, Dings, diese
Ausgabenstellen und
irgendwelche, also hier hängt alles
auf der, auf der Straße rum.
Da willst du nicht hin. Sieht von oben nicht so schlimm aus,
aber die Ecke hier ist richtig. Generell,
diese ganze Ecke hier auch am Hauptbahnhof,
auch, auch, auch, wenn du,
es ist im Prinzip, auch hier hängen auch viele rum,
wenn du von der Seite hier rüber, rüberläufst
zum,
wenn du hier so rüberläufst zum Hauptbahnhof
von, von der Seite. Es ist, ach, generell
Frankfurt ist einfach nur eklig.
Wieso ist eigentlich in jeder Stadt die Gegend
um den Hauptbahnhof die Assi-Gegend? Das ist eine gute
Frage. Ja, da sammelt sich irgendwie
alles. Und hier, also wenn,
übrigens noch was, wenn ihr beim Hauptbahnhof,
wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof reingeht,
dann geht vorne rein
oder,
oder nehmt diesen Seiteneingang auf der Seite,
nicht hier oben. Hier oben ist der
McDonalds irgendwo.
Hier ist der Mc...
Ne, hier. Hier, hier irgendwo an der Seite
ist der McDonalds-Eingang.
Sieht man hier gar nicht, aber irgendwo hier ist der
McDonalds-Eingang. Und
hier gammeln, also hier auf der Seite
so zu dem Eingang, hier
gammeln auch immer die ganzen Assis rum.
Da siehst du auch Leute,
Leute nackig rumlaufen und sowas tagsüber.
Und keine Leute, die man sich
gerne nackig angucken will, glaubts mir.
Alles andere als Hyper-Gachi, sage ich's.
Also in Berlin am Hauptbahnhof
fand ich auch eklig.
Nicht so, da ich da jetzt wahnsinnig oft gewesen bin.
Das erste Mal,
als ich in Berlin war, war zur Battlefield 1
Event. Ich war vorher noch nie in Berlin.
Und das erste,
was ich hatte, ich hab die Haupt-
ich hab die, die Tür aufgemacht.
Und was heißt die Tür?
Ich bin durch, ich bin durch den, den, den,
die Tür gelaufen, also den Ausgang vom Berliner Hauptbahnhof.
Und das erste, was mich war, hat
mich ja irgendein Penner ins Gesicht gehustet.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, jawoll.
Wieder heim.
Gibt's da Street View? Ja, da gibt's
Street View, allerdings nur Street View
von...
2006 oder so.
Wie? 2022?
What the fuck?
Die haben wirklich Street View wieder.
In Deutschland.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Pogge.
Ach, Privatperson hat Street View.
Ah, ok, ok, ok. Ja, komm. Guck mal. Guck mal. Guck mal. Guck mal. Guck mal. Guck mal. Guck mal.
Gucken wir uns mal, gucken wir uns mal die Assi-Ecke an hier.
Jedes Land hat ja mittlerweile
Street View, bloß Deutschland nicht.
Wo hab ich gesagt? Die Niederstraße.
Ist das hier oben die jetzt?
Ja, genau, hier so. Die Ecke. Die Ecke da ist.
Da ist
Assi-Stelz angesagt, Leute.
Ja.
Äh.
Nein.
Hier sieht man schon.
Hier sind schon die ganzen Spezialisten am Start.
Äh.
Na wobei. Ja, guck mal da.
Da sitzen schon. Da sitzen schon die ersten in der Ecke.
Und
und bereiten sich
ihre nächste Wahlzeit zu.
Da siehst du schon hier. Da hängt
eine auf der Erde. Da hängt eine auf
der Erde. Da werden sich die neuesten
Spritzen aufgezogen.
Mal hier lang. Oh.
Nein.
Keck. Ach, hier gibt's nix, oder was?
Ach, hier konnte der nicht durchfahren.
Deswegen. Weil hier hängen auch
immer gerne rum.
Also die Gegend, Leute. Ich sag euch. Die ist
wirklich.
Das ist. Da wollt ihr auf jeden Fall
nicht, nicht, nicht
langlaufen, ja. Irgendwo
hier hinten hab ich auch mal live nen.
Der hat zwar Überfall auf der Straße mitgekriegt.
Wo einer
zwei Mädels ausgeraubt hat.
Und das Blöde daran war, die kannten den
sogar. Die haben den dann, die haben dem dann
nachgerufen. Mit seinem Namen.
Der Typ war halt wahrscheinlich komplett
durch im Kopf. Und hat Leute
überfallen, die ihn kennen.
Nur in Frankfurt, Leute. Nur in Frankfurt.
Ja. Top. Top
Gegend hier. Ja, die ausgeraubten
kennen den. Die könnten zur Polizei gehen und sagen. Na, Karl hat
mich überfallen. Haben sie aber
anscheinend nicht. Oder weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ich hab
nix mitgekriegt.
Ich hab nur mitgekriegt, dass
einer von hinten angerannt gekommen ist.
Hat der eine auf den Kopf gehauen. Hat die
Tasche mitge... Also hat die die Tasche entrissen
und ist weggerannt. Und die haben wieder
hinterher geschrien. Karl! Was machst du denn?
Frankfurt only.
Frankfurt Gütestraße.
Louis Vuitton Store. Zahl die
Kollektion bar. Fick auf Sponsor.
Oh Mann.
So, was können wir uns denn angucken?
Useless. Don't buy
a Wifi Range Extender.
Jo. Naja, useless.
Useless
sind sie nicht zwangsläufig.
Kann ich schon dafür verwenden.
Ist halt, vor allem wenn man
Bandbreite haben will, nicht unbedingt so das Beste.
Kannst du ein Cloud Storage
empfehlen? Offsite Sicherung für... Achso,
ne, ne. Kenn ich mich aktuell nicht aus.
Ich hab
die hier ne Weile verwendet mal. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob die noch normales Zeug haben.
Und wie die Preise sind.
Mittlerweile.
Unlimited Data.
Die Hetzner Storage Box. Tatsächlich.
Ja, stimmt. Die gibt's ja auch noch.
Hetzner Cloud Prices.
Da müsste ich eigentlich mal wieder
sehr laut machen.
Prices. Storage.
Ist das die Storage Box?
Oh. Oh, ist ganz schön teuer.
Ey, AWS ist
sicherlich deutlich teurer.
Storage Boxes.
Hier. 20 Terabyte.
48 Euro.
Das ist preislich
durchaus in Ordnung.
Also ein Terabyte für 3 Euro
81 kann man sich durchaus gönnen.
Oder 5 für 12. Also 3 Euro
finde ich tatsächlich ganz gut. 1 Terabyte
Offsite reicht den meisten Leuten.
Ja, weil man halt auch wirklich mal guckt.
Was ist wichtig? Was muss ich wirklich
Offsite sichern?
Weil ich mein, irgendwelche
Okay, es seien dann Fotografen oder so.
Die kommen damit nicht hin.
Aber die ganzen Sachen, die wirklich viel
Speicher brauchen. Von
VM-Images bis sonst was. Die muss man ja nicht
wirklich Offsite sichern.
Also ich finde gerade das erste ist gar nicht
mal so übel.
So, was können wir uns angucken, Leute?
Zeig her.
Warte, ich hab ein Problem. Ich muss nochmal aufs Klo vorher.
Es ging noch nicht, bevor ich den
Stream angemacht hab.
Aber jetzt drückt's.
Warte, ich bin mal kurz. Ich bin mal kurz.
Afk.
Pipo. Pupu.
Bin gleich wieder da.
So.
So. Fertig.
Kein Multitasking.
Doch, ich hab ein Wireless-Headset.
Aber nicht angeschlossen und ich nehm mein
Wireless-Headset bestimmt nicht wieder aufs Klo.
Wobei, ohne Scheiß, in der heutigen
Zeit, wo Pool-Streams gemacht werden, warum
sollte man da keine Klo-Streams machen?
Wenn man schon
so ein expensive Klo daheim hat,
kann man das ja auch wenigstens dann
zum Geldverdienen benutzen.
Pipo-Pupu-Streams
war man dann, ja.
Boah, wahrscheinlich gibt's auch noch Leute,
die stehen auf sowas. Ich will's mir gar nicht
ausmalen.
Ins Gym.
Haben die sonntags auf, ja?
Anscheinend. Da könnt's ja nicht hingehen.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Hättest du mal Gigabit
jetzt, ja? So.
Also, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
This FPS is dead.
Last
than a year after launch.
Äh. Ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass ihr über Modern Warfare redet.
Das wäre relativ sinnlos und jeder weiß,
dass es jetzt dead ist.
Installing Mac OS on a Microsoft
Laptop.
22 Minuten,
Mensch, äh. Da hätte ich ein bisschen was
kürzer und knackigeres.
Floppys Disk Supplier
Moment. Wollen die uns ernsthaft erzählen,
Leute kaufen heute mal...
Business is booming?
Also,
das kann ich
nur beschränkt glauben.
Sekunde.
Take a look at this.
This is a floppy disk
from the 1970s.
Ja.
Wie wär's, wenn die einfach nicht Musik drüber gemacht hätten,
wenn er redet?
Also, nur so? No.
People who go in the back of their warehouse
and might find a pallet or two
of the floppy disks
and they're about to take them to the dump,
they may call us up and say, hey,
will you take these off our hands?
And we say happily, yes.
Ja, gut.
Genau, nichts damit, dass das Business jetzt booming wäre.
An wen verkauft er die denn?
I would say the biggest users are people in the embroidery business.
In was?
Was ist das?
Embroidery business?
Das Wort habe ich noch nie gehört.
There are a lot of people in the tool and die business
who use floppy disks.
Most people
don't know that about
Stickerei?
Ach, du meinst, dass man damit diese
irgendwelche Maschinen mitprogrammieren kann,
oder?
to a half of all the aircraft flying today.
Aber der hat hier die highly advanced
floppy disk
quick draw skills.
Guck mal her.
A third to a half of all
the aircraft flying today
were built 20 years ago.
Ja.
And if you built a plane
20 or 30 or even 40 years ago,
you would use
a floppy disk to get information
in and out of some of the avionics
Meint ihr wirklich,
die meisten Flugzeuge heute verwenden
echt noch Disketten?
Die wurden noch nicht abgecradert auf irgendwas?
Huh?
500 Disketten am Tag!
Gut, die krasse Menge ist das jetzt
auch nicht.
Ein floppy auf USB-Adapter.
Ja, sowas.
Das wär mal high IQ. Auf der einen Seite
quasi so eine fake floppy disk
und auf der anderen Seite einen USB-Stick.
Das gibt's bestimmt.
Moment, Moment.
Floppy disk USB-Adapter.
Ja, Moment. Es gibt...
Nee, nee, ich meinte jetzt eigentlich
eher das Umgedrehte.
Dass man quasi so eine fake Diskette hat,
wo man einen USB-Stick dran anschließt.
Sowas da, ja.
...wanna have these discs
but it's not forever.
Wow,
war nicht so krach.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, 500 Disketten
am Tag, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das
booming ist.
Früher hast du einen Diskettenpack gekauft,
das waren 10 Stück drinnen.
Ja, also...
Weiß nicht, wie das da war.
Gut, ich mein für die heutige Zeit ist
natürlich trotzdem viel, da würde man nicht
denken, dass ein Händler 500 Disketten verkauft.
Aber insgesamt ist es nicht viel.
Ich hab mir damals auch immer so CD's
oder CD-Spindeln gekauft.
Da waren 50 oder 100 glaube ich sogar CDs drinnen.
So eine CD-RW-Spindel.
So ein Ding.
Guck hier.
Nicht 10er-Pack-Keckel.
Hier, sowas hat man sich da gekauft, wenn schon.
Hier.
Sowas hat man sich damals gekauft hier.
50er-Pack.
CD-Rohlinge.
Und da wurde gebrannt.
Das ist ja auch total out.
Habt ihr überhaupt noch einen CD-Brenner
oder einen DVD-Brenner oder irgendwie
ein optisches Laufwerk?
Also fragen wir mal zwei Sachen.
Erstens, habt ihr noch ein optisches Laufwerk
im Rechner?
Und zweitens, habt ihr einen CD-Brenner
beziehungsweise DVD-Brenner im Rechner?
Extern.
Ja gut, zählt auch.
Einfach nur angeschlossen.
Tatsächlich.
Also ich glaube, ich hatte die letzten
wahrscheinlich schon
10 Jahre oder so.
Nein, vielleicht nicht ganz 10.
Ja, vielleicht doch 10.
Also die letzten zwei Rechner hatten beide kein
optisches Laufwerk mehr.
Oh, jetzt wird es aber advanced.
Guck mal da.
Ein externes Disketten-Laufwerk
und ein Brenner mit Light Scribe.
Ja, das gab es damals ja auch,
dass man dort auf die CDs oben dann so ein bisschen
Beschriftungen gravieren konnte.
Ein Blu-Ray-Brenner.
Ein MoDrive.
Kennt ihr noch Dings hier?
Kennt ihr mal noch diese Dinger?
Das war damals der Shit.
Man war unglaublich beeindruckt,
dass man 100 Megabyte
oder waren es nur 80?
Oder waren es 120?
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so ganz sicher.
Ich habe jetzt...
Ich habe im Hinterkopf 100.
Dass man 100 MB auf eine Diskette
bekommen hat.
Die Dinger waren halt langsam
as fuck, ja.
Das hat da nie jemand benutzt.
Click of Death.
Das ist der Vorgänger vom
Xbox oder wie?
Wie schnell waren denn die Dinger?
Ich kann mich daran erinnern,
die waren unglaublich langsam.
Die waren nicht blazingly fast.
Hier, guck mal.
1,4 MB die Sekunde.
Ich meine gut, 100 MB?
Du hast halt 1,5 Minuten ungefähr kopiert.
100 MB.
Das war in der damaligen Zeit durchaus
in Ordnung.
Ich meine, ein normaler Floppy-Disk
hatte das halt Gesamtkapazität,
oder so.
Angeschlossen wurden die Dinger, glaube ich,
hauptsächlich tatsächlich über SCSI.
Oder SCSI,
wie das die Leute nennen.
Teilweise.
Ich persönlich bin ja für SCSI,
nicht für SCSI.
Oder manche sagen auch SCSI,
oder sowas ähnliches.
Okay, es gab sogar
USB-Varianten, das ist mir neu.
FireWire oder UltraBay.
Was zum Teufel ist UltraBay?
Ach, irgendwas von IBM.
Per IDE-Kabel.
Die meisten Leute werden es über IDE-Kabel
angeschlossen haben.
Und falls sich noch irgendjemand
daran erinnern kann, IDE
Masters, das darf man heute wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mehr so nennen,
Master Slave Cable Select.
Da gab es noch
Jumper
an den Geräten.
Und man musste gucken,
dass man nicht etwa aus Versehen
das
CD-Laufwerk als Master macht
und die Festplatte als Slave und solche Sachen.
Das war noch nicht ganz so idiotensicher
wie heute.
Wobei es eigentlich auch schon relativ simpel gewesen ist.
Aber trotzdem, da konnte man noch mehr verkacken.
Jumper.
Hinten an der Festplatte und am CD-Laufwerk.
Ich glaube, aktuelle Laufwerke
haben gar keinen Jumper mehr.
Oder haben aktuelle SATA-SSDs
also SSDs auf keinen Fall, aber
haben noch Festplatten
Jumper? Nee, oder?
Ich habe mir schon eine Weile keine Festplatte
mehr von hinten angeguckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Tab-Management.
Ah, wir haben noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, das waren auch Zeiten hier.
Und wer das noch nicht gesehen hat,
das waren
solche
Dinger.
Übrigens, ähnliche
Dinger hatte man damals auch
für Druckeranschlüsse
verwendet, also optisch sahen
die ähnlich aus.
Damals hat man Grafikkarten auch nicht
per PCI-Express angeschlossen,
sondern per AGP-Slot.
Das war quasi
der PCI-Express-Vorgänger.
Ist auch genug Boomer-Zeug.
Was können wir uns denn angucken?
Zeig ich mal her.
This FPS is dead.
Last year after launch.
Gut, 5 Minuten können wir uns angucken.
Also, wenn das wirklich Modern Warfare
2019 ist, dann muss ich aber
kecken. Kann es aber nicht sein,
dass es darum geht.
Game Awards, juckt das überhaupt
irgendjemand noch?
What?
Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Ich kann mich legit absolut nicht dran erinnern,
was das für ein Game sein soll.
9 to 5?
Sagt mir absolut
gar nichts!
Habt ihr das schon mal gehört?
Sagt mir Null! Keine Ahnung, was
das ist!
9 to 5?
Gut, das sind Ami-Arbeitszeiten, aber
hä?
PS, where your main goal was to kill
enemies, unlock corporation gear,
customize your weapons. Hab ich noch nie was
von gehört. The premise for the game was actually really
awesome. Three teams of three compete
to complete objectives in a round
based system. And the better your team
did early on, the better advantages
you had. Hab ich
legit noch nie was von gehört.
The following rounds. It was being
developed by Red Hill Games, which
was a big studio comprised of industry veterans.
And although the talent was there
and the vision seemed promising at first,
the studio failed to get their footing in the
multiplayer space. And after about
three years of development, alphas,
betas, an early access release
in August of 2021, and
then a release out of early access.
You mightのでa think, hey,
der tour konnte ja was für euch sein.
You open the page in Steam,
and the first thing you see is this game
in early access. And then
I'll keep it closed
to the side.
I don't play any early access
games as a principle. And I'd
prefer to, I could
in Steam completely
filter out early access.
Unfortunately that does not work.
Well, Battlefield 2042
is an early access,
if at all sold out.
Mich würde mal eine Statistik interessieren, wie viel, also prozentual gesehen, ja, wie viel der Games, die in Early Access gehen, werden fertiggestellt?
Was würdet ihr schätzen, Chat? Also ich würde sagen, 20%, wenn es hochkommt. Wenn es hochkommt, 20%, werden jemals fertig.
Oder was meint ihr, wie viel es sind? Also ich sage 20%, aber wie gesagt, das ist wahrscheinlich schon viel zu viel.
50%, 50%, es gibt so viele Games, die rauskommen und verschimmeln im Early Access.
Ja, also ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen. Also ich würde am liebsten Early Access komplett rausfiltern auf Steam.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, wo ich mir denke, ey, cool, und dann sehe ich Early Access und dann mache ich gleich zu.
Was fertiggestellt ist, ja gut, das ist Definitionsfrage, ganz einfach.
Ich würde es ganz naheliegend machen. Sobald es halt eben...
Aus Early Access rauskommt, sobald es kein Early Access Tag mehr hat.
Sobald es laut dem Hersteller quasi fertig, sag mal fertig heißt ja nicht, dass es keinen Support mehr gibt,
aber reif zum Release ist, ja, sobald es kein Early Access Tag mehr hat.
Also wie viel Prozent der Spiele vom Early Access wirklich zu, können ja auch der Hersteller selbst definieren, fertig sind.
Aber 20%, wenn es hochkommt. Ich würde mich echt mal interessieren, ob es da eine Statistik gibt.
Da ist richtig viel Müll dabei, das ist halt das Problem.
Ich glaube, das einzige Early Access Spiel, was ich jemals länger gespielt habe, war Factorio.
Factorio ist aber auch richtig nice gewesen da schon.
Und man hat halt auch gesehen, der arbeitet da gefühlt irgendwie täglich dran.
Und das Release war dann auch, glaube ich, nur noch irgendwie angekündigt, irgendwie nur in zwei Monaten oder so.
Factorio ist... Also ohne Scheiß, Factorio ist...
Echt der high IQsten Spiele, die es gibt.
Ihr müsst mal gucken, was da Leute mittlerweile mit bauen, das ist echt nicht mehr normal.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das eigentliche Problem gewesen.
Ihr wisst, was?
Ihr wisst doch, wie das ist. Wenn es um Potenzial geht, kannst du das fast jedem Game nachsagen.
Ich meine, Battlefield 2042, das hat auch Potenzial, gerade mit Portal gehabt.
Aber die Frage ist ja auch, ob man dieses Potenzial irgendwie nutzt.
Und das... Tja, Potenzial alleine reicht halt nicht.
Alas, im Oktober dieses Jahres haben wir die Nachrichten erhoben, dass 9-5 die Entwicklung stoppen wird,
mit Servers being shut down on January 18th of 2023.
The developer posted a heartfelt announcement to social media,
Ist das... Ist das World War 3? Nein, das ist 9-5. Habe ich auch noch nichts von gehört.
...media claiming that they will no longer be developing their own games
and will instead focus on working with other game devs on co-developing projects.
They also disabled in-game purchases and made all premium skins and bundles free for everyone to use.
Na immerhin.
And they also signed off with this...
Da haben bestimmt dann alle die Premium Sachen gekauft.
Haben übelst reingehatet.
...message.
We want to emphasize how grateful we are to you, our community.
Our close-knit relationship and connection are very special to us.
Your enthusiasm, patience and support for our game has been overwhelming
and we couldn't have gotten this far without you.
And although the game didn't resonate with many, myself included,
it does feel bitter...
Container Maps!
Haben die... haben die ex... haben die ex-DICE-Developer?
...sweet, all the same.
When you have developers who were clearly passionate about their game,
be forced to shut it down prematurely...
Aber ich muss sagen, ehrlich gesagt, es sieht eigentlich ganz spaßig aus.
Aber sieht ganz spaßig aus, hat anscheinend nicht gereicht.
...and now are no longer pursuing creating their own game.
Das Waffenhandling sieht ein bisschen unrund aus.
It kind of sucks.
Aber gut, kann man jetzt nicht sagen.
And this is why creating solid PvP multiplayer games in this day and age is such a risk.
If you can't get a player base who supports the vision early on,
many will instantly write the game off as dead.
Also, ich mach das ganz anders.
Bei mir ist es komplett anders.
Solange da Early Access dransteht, gucke ich es erst gar nicht an.
...before it even has a chance to live.
Gerade, gerade wenn man es kaufen soll im Early Access.
...live.
Granted, with 9 to 5, there were a ton of questionable design choices
that made players scratch their heads.
But a ton of games have felt that pressure, a lot of which I cover on this channel.
World War 3 has been dead and resurrected...
World War 3...
Also, der Grund, warum ich World War 3 mir nicht mehr angeguckt hab, ist MailRU Anti-Cheat.
Ich mein, Anti-Cheats sind ja mittlerweile schon schlimm genug.
Aber will man wirklich noch den Russen Anti-Cheat auf dem Rechner haben?
...many times, with player bases hitting single digits.
Der hat kein MailRU Anti-Cheat mehr?
Ja, der hat jetzt den Nachfolger von MailRU Anti-Cheat drinne.
Hell, PvP multiplayer almost killed...
...Ready or Not completely.
Was Ready or Not hatte zwischenzeitlich? Multiplayer?
Ich dachte, das ist so Single-Player...
...super realistisch...
...Kampagnen-Ding.
Ne, nicht Kampagnen-Ding, Koop-Ding.
...Video on Ready or Not the other day,
when they pivoted back to what originally made them sell,
which was their co-op experience,
and that game is still sitting in the best spot that it's ever been.
If you guys haven't seen that video, I'm gonna have it linked down below,
...I'm gonna have it linked down below,
and it'll also be linked in the top right of this video.
The fact is, if you're coming out of the gate in the multiplayer space,
you're competing against the juggernauts in the Battle Royale category,
you're competing against juggernauts in the competitive shooter category,
companies that have millions of dollars, infinite resources to create games,
give them to players for free,
and then create a pipeline of skins and battle passes and content drip
to keep those same players engaged and their wallets empty.
It's becoming harder and harder for indie devs
with a fraction of that budget to compete for gamers' attention.
And as developers, you have to fight the urge to create the game that you want to make
and instead bend and create the games that you think players might want to see
or try to fill a void in the market that most likely isn't even there anymore.
I love multiplayer shooters, and I always said when I looked at 9to5,
the game could have so much potential, but in order for it to do so,
the developers had to change their vision so much
that it wouldn't be the same game that they originally set out to make.
It just didn't have a place in today's market.
And that, ladies and gentlemen, is the sad reality of 9to5,
a game made by passionate developers who couldn't capitalize
on what adult FPS gamers were looking for.
I still wish Red Hill Games the best,
and I look forward to seeing the games that they co-develop in the future,
but for now,
leave a like on the video if you enjoyed it.
I'll see you guys in the next video.
Bye!
Subtitles by Stephanie Geiges
Ich weiß nicht.
Komplett dem Trend hinterherrennen,
das mag vielleicht schon erfolgreich sein,
wenn du wirklich Millionen und Milliarder hast
und massig Developer-Resourcen und alles Mögliche.
Aber ich glaube, gerade wenn du jetzt ein normales Studio bist
oder gerade auch ein einzelner Entwickler,
vielleicht mit zwei, drei anderen Leuten,
warum solltest du auf irgendwie den riesen Zug aufspringen,
nur weil das gerade anders ist?
Oder weil das gerade angesagt ist?
Dann ist doch besser,
du machst ein gutes Game,
was dir selbst gefällt
und schaffst damit, andere davon zu begeistern.
Auch wenn es halt dann keine Millionen sind,
kann nicht jeder das nächste Flappy Bird.
Ich mein ganz im Ernst,
es kann doch eh keiner wirklich abschätzen so richtig,
welche Games jetzt trenden und was nicht.
Seriously, meint ihr,
der Typ, der Flappy Bird programmiert hat,
hat gedacht,
Alter,
jetzt sind das neueste geile Game,
was Millionen spielen werden.
Nee, der hat irgendein Programmiertutorial
oder sowas wahrscheinlich gemacht.
Ich mein, Flappy Bird ist ja so ziemlich das Simpelste an Games,
was du machen konntest
und aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat das so viral voll eingeschlagen.
Man muss sich nur mal Hand anschauen,
das spielen die Devs selbst.
Ja, es ist immer ein gutes Zeichen dafür,
wenn die Entwickler selbst ihre Games spielen
und daraufhin halt auch vielleicht Sachen anpassen im Game.
Das ist halt eine Sache,
die ich mir nicht vorstellen kann,
dass bei DICE das großartig passiert.
Also, sie haben ihre Games schon gespielt.
Man hat ja ein bisschen,
also, manche Leute haben das Game gespielt.
Man hat aber das Gameplay gesehen, Leute.
Könnt ihr euch noch auf dem Reveal-Stream an das Gameplay erinnern?
Oh, warte mal.
Oder war das bei dem,
nee, sorry, Leute.
Nicht im Reveal-Stream.
Das war in dem Event, wo ich eingeladen habe.
Hab ich ganz vergessen.
In dem Event,
ähm,
das wurde gar nicht gestreamt.
In dem Event hat man Gameplay gesehen von einem DICE-Entwickler.
Und Leute,
kein Wunder, dass Battlefield so geworden ist,
wie es geworden ist, Alter.
Wie die das Game gespielt haben,
ist absoluter Wahnsinn.
Der Kerl ist nur mit C4 über die Map geflogen.
Der ist,
müsst ihr euch vorstellen,
der Kerl ist auf Orbital,
auf die,
auf die, ähm,
die Antennen und Hochhäuser hochgelaufen.
Für zwei Minuten hat nichts anderes gemacht.
Ist hochgelaufen
und ist dann von dort runtergesprungen
und mit dem Fallschirm geflogen
und hat C4 von oben auf die Leute geschmissen.
Und das war das Ganze,
also das hat er die ganze Zeit gemacht.
Das ganze Match über.
Da wurdest du,
da wurdest du nicht echt nett.
Ja.
Aber die hätten wirklich ihr Game mal mehr spielen sollen.
Ich mein, ich sag's,
ich, ich hab's jetzt schon öfters als Beispiel gebracht, ja.
Es gibt ja ein paar Konferenztalks von,
von id Software früher,
von, von den Doom-Entwicklern
und den Quake-Entwicklern,
die gesagt haben,
sie wollten,
also sie haben den Kram nicht nur selbst gespielt,
sie wollten das Game machen,
was sie selbst spielen wollten
und vor allem,
bei ihnen gab's kein Burnout oder sowas.
Das war quasi ihr Leben,
so das Spiel zu,
die, die Games zu entwickeln
und zu spielen.
Das war sogar so schlimm,
dass, dass einer gesagt hat,
wenn er aufs Klo geht,
geht's ihm quasi schlecht,
weil er nicht weiterprogrammieren kann.
Und, und dann hat er sich irgendwelche Stände
aufm Klo gebaut,
dass er aufm Klo, äh,
irgendwie seinen, seinen,
seinen PC hinstellen konnte
und dann, oder seinen Laptop,
ich weiß nicht, ob's schon Laptop waren,
dass er dann aufm Klo
weiterprogrammieren konnte.
Also sprich,
dem, der hat, der hat gemeint,
ihm ging's quasi schlecht,
weil er mal aufs Klo musste,
weil dann konnte er nicht weiterentwickeln.
Das ist okay,
das war auch noch andere Zeit,
okay, aber,
hey, ich mein,
immerhin,
die, die, die finden ihr,
ihr Game selbst halt geil.
Ist doch, ist doch,
das, das, was vielen Games
heute auch noch fehlt.
Ja, den hätte Elon Musk gemacht,
wahrscheinlich.
Willst du mal Warzone 2 streamen?
Dazu müsste ich Warzone 2
erst mal eine Weile spielen.
Wie gesagt,
ich hab immer nur eine Runde
bisher erst gespielt.
So eine richtige Runde.
Solo ins, in Quartz
und hab ein paar Leute gekillt
und, äh,
Gulag gewonnen
und dann wurd ich halt überrannt, ja.
Aber wo wir grade dabei sind,
komm, wir hören uns jetzt den Rant an.
Der Thunderlord,
der, der, der German Thunderlord,
der erklärt uns jetzt,
warum Warzone 2 eine Zumutung ist.
Das wollt ich gestern schon gucken.
Der rantet immer so schön,
auch über die,
über Battlefield.
Und am lustigsten find ich immer,
wenn ich mir ihn dann angucke,
wenn er Heli fliegt, ja,
und sich darüber aufregt,
dass es irgendjemand wagt,
auf den Heli zu schießen.
Das ist auch immer geil, so,
so nach dem Motto,
äh, alles Kack-Noobs hier,
krasser Heli-Skill.
Was?
Da schießt einer auf mein Heli.
Ah, alle mit dem Noob-Raketenwerfer
auch noch.
Mein Gott, scheiß Entwickler.
Warum ist der Noob-Raketenwerfer
und die Noob-Rakete
und die Noob-Granate?
Naja, guck ich mir trotzdem immer gerne an.
So, es ist immer noch übertrieben
in Battlefield 2042, so.
Hallo, heute geht es um Warzone 2.
Es ist mir an dieser Stelle
schon mal ein persönliches Anliegen,
der redet immer so wahnsinnig motiviert,
irgendwie auch,
euch eine Vorabwarnung zu geben,
dass das hier eines der negativsten Videos
auf diesem Kanal werden wird.
Okay, auf geht's, auf geht's.
Das soll schon nicht was heißen.
Es wird außerdem das einzige Video sein,
was ich noch zu MW2 hier
auf dem Kanal haben werde,
weil es so traurig ist,
weil es so traurig und so frech ist,
was sie hier abgeliefert haben,
dass ich mir das nicht weiter antun möchte.
Das ist genau für eine Sache gut,
nämlich jetzt hier ein Video zu machen.
Die Noobs.
Das ist für eine Sache gut.
Ich dachte, jetzt erzählt er mir da was
über Noobs und Casual-Spieler.
Da erzählt er auch immer gerne was drüber.
... bis 100 Euro durch das Video mitzunehmen,
um mich dann zu freuen...
Ja, hat er nicht unrecht.
... dass ich sozusagen Schmerzensgeld dafür bekomme,
mir diese Qual angetan zu haben.
Hat er nicht unrecht?
Vielleicht soll ich auch ein Video
zu Warzone 2 machen.
Gibt auf jeden Fall gut Views
und Kohle aktuell.
Und ich gebe euch Brief und Siegel dafür.
Würde das hier nicht unter dem Titel
Call of Duty stehen,
es hätte innerhalb von einer Woche
keine Spieler mehr,
weil es auch keine Spieler verdient.
Und jeder, der das hier noch weiter spielt,
ist offensichtlich ein Vollidiot.
Jetzt geht's zur Sache.
Das kann man sich ausdrücken.
Es tut mir leid, Leute.
Es ist aber wirklich so.
Und ich sage das,
obwohl ich Warzone 1 gut fand.
Das kam raus, es hat Spaß gemacht,
es hat funktioniert.
Vor allem hat es funktioniert.
Die Frage ist,
wird das genauso letztes Warzone-Video
bei ihm wie meine letzten
Battlefield 2042-Videos sein?
Ja, ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Nächsten Dienstag kommt die neue Season.
Da werde ich auch noch was zu machen.
Guckt euch diese Scheiße an.
Hier funktioniert überhaupt nichts.
Es ist einfach eine einzige Shit-Show,
dieses Game auf einer Stufe
als kaputt zu bezeichnen
mit anderen kaputten Spielen
wie Fallout 76 oder Battlefield 2042.
Es scheint ein wenig kaputt zu sein, oder?
Immer noch eine fucking Beleidigung.
Ich habe schon wenig erwartet,
aber ich wurde immer noch enttäuscht.
Ich habe wenigstens erwartet...
Alter, ich habe das Video
jetzt schon zweimal leiser gemacht.
Der wurde immer lauter über die ganze Minute.
...dass es funktioniert.
Aber selbst das ist nicht der Fall.
Wenn man überhaupt spielen kann.
Ihr seht das ja hier gerade.
Ich will starten.
Es geht nicht.
Ja gut, das Problem hatte ich auch.
Muss ich aber ehrlich sagen,
das war halt auch am Releasetag.
Und dass es am Releasetag Probleme gibt
mit Server und Matchmaking,
da habe ich schon fast mit gerechnet.
Es erzählt mir, ich soll das Game kaufen.
Ich rufe die FL auf,
es erzählt mir, ich soll das Game kaufen.
Das verdammte Spiel.
Solche Dinge passieren.
Ja, das Menü und das Squadmanagement
ist eh komplette Zumutung.
Am laufenden Band.
Die ganze fucking Zeit.
Sogar bei Leuten,
die das fucking Game gekauft haben.
Oh, oh, oh, jetzt geht's los.
Ich muss mich zusammenreißen.
Ich schreie schon wieder rum,
obwohl ich nicht mal Geld
in das Game gesteckt habe.
Regt es mich trotzdem so auf,
weil es eine Frechheit ist,
weil es so schlecht ist
und weil ich mich frage,
wie sowas passieren kann.
Und wenn man dann spielen kann,
Traste da aus.
Dann kann man endlich
in dieser tollen Wüstenmap
mit RPG, AK und Bombendrohne
den inneren Terroristen empfehlen.
Da kommt doch Freude auf
in der perfekt passenden Gegend dazu.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr habt.
Das ist doch eine super Map.
Und dann drücke ich hier
ein paar Mal auf den Zünden Knopf
und dann wirft mein Charakter
erst mal das scheiß Sem Text.
Super, erst mal Sem Text gewastet.
Kommt Freude auf.
Aber jetzt mal Spaß beiseite.
Diese Map hier hat auch
so ihre Probleme.
Offensichtlich wisst ihr,
was zum Beispiel richtig geil ist.
Es gibt jetzt so neue Black Sides.
Dafür braucht man ein Schlüssel,
um reinzukommen.
Und dann nimmt man hier
einen Auftrag an,
wo man irgendwelche Tresore
aufsprengen muss.
Und dann ist der in der Bibliothek.
Da ist ein Black Side drin,
wo man nicht rein kann.
Ja gut, das stimmt schon.
Das Spiel hat also generell muss man
das muss man auch wirklich mal sagen.
Also Modern Warfare 2
hat an vielen Stellen
echt so einen Feintuning Problem einfach.
Also das ist jetzt nicht,
dass es einfach komplett broken ist,
wie am Anfang Battlefield 2042
ist es in vielen Fällen auch.
Aber es ist einfach so so unüberlegt,
nicht unüberlegt,
so als fehlt immer was.
Ich meine,
so wie es ist,
als hat jemand quasi schon
das richtig programmiert.
Es funktioniert,
aber es fühlt sich nicht so an.
Ja, beispielsweise,
wenn du reinlädst in die Map,
dann kommt der Ladebildschirm zweimal.
Das Menü freest immer zwischendurch.
Wenn Leute in dein Squad reinjoinen,
dann ruckelt das erst mal ganz gut.
Das ist so.
Ja, prinzipiell ist das da,
aber eigentlich müsste es jetzt
noch mal hübsch gemacht werden.
Und das hat man nicht gemacht.
Ja, so fühlt sich das an.
Dann kann ich an die Tresore ran.
Gratulation.
Wisst ihr,
wofür diese Black Side Scheiße da ist?
Es gibt neue PvE-Zonen.
Ja, PvE-Zonen.
Das habe ich auch mitgekriegt.
Da rennen dann Bots rum
und die kann man umbringen.
Und das da,
das ist ein Spieler.
das ist ein Bot.
Und ich sage euch,
PvE und PvP in einem Battle Royale
zu mischen,
ist sehr schwierig.
In Fallout 76,
im Nuclear Winter Battle Royale,
haben die das besser hinbekommen
als hier.
Da haben sie es nämlich
einigermaßen vernünftig hinbekommen.
Hier sind die Bots
tatsächlich ziemlich tödlich
und sie greifen,
warum auch immer,
die anderen Spieler
hier auch nicht vernünftig an.
Dass man den Unterschied
zwischen Spieler und Bot
hat, ist eigentlich bescheuert.
Ich bin PEGA.
... rum und mischen sich
unter die Bots.
Und weil das alles irgendwie
scheiße aussieht
mit diesen ganzen diversen
Bullshit-Skins,
die es in diesem Game gibt,
kann man die von außen
teilweise nicht mal gut erkennen.
Und wofür das ist,
dass man einen Haufen Loot bekommt,
der sich teilweise ineinander backt,
sodass man ihn nicht mal
aufsammeln kann.
Gratulation.
Und möglicherweise
ein Black-Side-Schlüssel,
womit man dann
zu einer Black-Side eiern kann,
wenn man da hoffentlich
lebendig ankommt.
Ja, da kann man dann...
Das ist eines
der neuen Möglichkeiten,
wie man Waffen
und Loadouts bekommen kann.
Diese PvE-Missionen.
Ob es das wirklich gebraucht hätte?
Ich bin mir da auch unschlüssig.
... runter und dann kommt
ein fucking Juggernaut-NPC-Boss,
der tankt und tankt und tankt.
So viele Headshots,
C4-Päckchen auch noch.
Er tankt und tankt und tankt.
Es ist ihm egal.
Wisst ihr,
die in Fallout 76
bei Nuclear Winter,
die haben verstanden,
wenn man PvE-Gegner,
auch PvE-Boss-Gegner
in seinem Battle Royale hat,
dann müssen die trotzdem
verdammt schnell sterben,
weil die Ablenkung,
die man durch die hat,
allein schon ausreichend ist,
dass es einen umbringt,
weil dann stimmt es
nicht mehr.
Es müssen Spieler ankommen,
die das Schießen hören
und sich denken,
ja, man, da gehen jetzt
abgelenkte Leute ab.
Das ist so, ja.
Genau so passiert das
unter Garantie auch ständig hier.
So ist es uns zumindest passiert.
Bei dem einen Mal,
wo ich das dann hier gemacht habe
für Video-Zwecke.
Komisch, oder?
Dass die Vollversager
bei Bug-Tester,
die von PvP überhaupt
keine Ahnung haben
und mit Fallout 76
ein historisch schlechtes Game
abgeliefert haben,
da noch bessere
Design-Entscheidungen treffen,
als die bei COD
mit Jahren der Erfahrung
in Sachen PvP.
Die denken sich dann...
Jetzt will er es wissen.
Oh, letztes Mal.
Let's go, Bullet Sponge.
Ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen.
Wie kann man so geistig...
Ich darf es ja nicht sagen,
sonst wird das Video
wieder gestriked.
Zur Belohnung für den
ganzen Spaß kriegt man
neben noch mehr Loot
dann einen Umfeld-Scan
um den ganzen Laden
drum herum,
der einem wenig bringt,
weil man da weg muss,
eine verbesserte Drohne,
die die Blickrichtung
der Gegner anzeigt,
was durchaus nice ist,
und eine Minigun,
die einem nur im Nahkampf
was bringt,
weil sie auf Range
ziemlich schlecht ist.
Supertoll, oder?
Seht ihr das hier?
Die Fights im Gulag...
Das ist der Gulag, ja.
Haben sie jetzt auch verkackt.
Ja, das muss ich sagen,
finde ich auch keine gute Idee.
Ich verstehe nicht den Sinn dahinter,
warum es 2 vs. 2 ist.
Vielleicht, weil man dort
die Sachen im 2 vs. 2 Modus
recyceln kann.
Keine Ahnung.
Warum es 2 vs. 2 ist,
finde ich, leuchtet mir auch
absolut nicht ein.
Zumal es ja dann auch noch
einen Boss-Gegner gibt,
den ehrlich gesagt
nie jemand macht.
Mit Randoms zusammen,
manchmal auch mit Teammates zusammen,
wenn es vom Timing her passt,
aber nicht immer.
Teilweise ist es auch so,
dass die Teammates
zur gleichen Zeit gespielt werden.
Wenn sie nicht gestorben sind,
aber in ein anderes Gulag gekommen sind.
Ist doch toll, oder?
Ist doch geil.
Und auch hier rennt dann
ein NPC-Juggernaut mit der Minigun rum,
der einem auf den Sack geht.
Warum?
Warum macht man sowas?
Was soll das?
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht genau,
warum es 2 vs. 2 sein muss.
Wer hat darum gebeten?
Wie, glaube ich, schon erwähnt.
Die späteren Zeiten...
Gebeten hat bei den ganzen Sachen
da nie jemand drum.
Von Warzone 1 habe ich nicht gespielt.
Vielleicht haben Leute darum gebeten.
Ich glaube aber nicht,
dass Leute darum gebeten haben.
Es werden nicht Sachen gemacht unbedingt,
weil die Spieler das haben wollen.
Weil sowas eine dumme Idee ist.
Warum macht man das dann?
Apropos, man kann jetzt auch im Gulag looten,
beispielsweise eine Dreierweste
und die behält man dann.
Das ist wenigstens mal eine ganz coole Idee,
dass man da nicht komplett nackt
aus dem Gulag rauskommt quasi.
Nackig.
Und die andere gute Sache,
um wenigstens diesen Scheiß
mal in einer Hinsicht zu loben,
ist der Zug, den es auf dieser Map gibt,
der dann auch Loot drauf hat
und durch die Gegend fährt
und wo man auch auf dem Zug fighten kann.
Das fand ich ganz cool.
Das hat Spaß gemacht.
Aber das ist auch irgendwie
die einzige Sache,
die ich dieser Map
und bei Extension
diesem ganzen Modus abgewählt habe.
Ansonsten ist es wirklich
von vorne bis hinten
eine einzige Shit-Show
und ich habe dann noch
so viel mehr Clips,
um das zu demonstrieren.
Hier beispielsweise.
Ich möchte mich anschließen.
Geht nicht.
Ist toll, oder?
Funktioniert einfach nicht.
Das ist kaputt.
Ja, das Partysystem
ist tatsächlich komplett kaputt.
Wir hatten auch ein riesen...
Also, ich habe es bei Battle.net.
Ein Kollege von mir hat es bei Steam.
Und wir wollten zusammen spielen.
Leute, wisst ihr,
wie lange es gedauert hat,
bis ich meine Activision-ID gefunden habe
beziehungsweise eher seine Activision-ID.
Und ich habe dann
gemerkt,
dass wir miteinander spielen konnten,
dass wir überhaupt erstmal
Freundesanfragen schicken konnten.
Wir haben bestimmt
jeder fünf Minuten geguckt,
wo dieser Kack steht.
Man findet es dann irgendwie
über Profil und Party
und eigenes Profil
und dann steht das irgendwo.
Und danach ging das Inviten nicht.
Wir haben uns gegenseitig invited.
Keine Chance.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Bei ihm ist der Invite
erst gar nicht angekommen.
Ich konnte bei ihm nicht joinen
über den Invite.
Wisst ihr,
was dann funktioniert hat?
Wisst ihr, wie es dann ging?
Ich musste bei mir im Profil einstellen,
dass ich online bin.
Normalerweise bin ich ja immer
als Offline angezeigt.
Und dann musste er mir reinjoinen
in die Party,
die ich geöffnet habe.
Das hat dann funktioniert.
Der Invite hat nicht funktioniert.
Also das ist wirklich
komplett im Arsch der Kram.
Es klappt nicht.
Manchmal klappt es,
manchmal klappt es nicht.
Das ist Next Gen.
Ich habe hier übrigens
den Clip gecuttet.
Der Ladescreen ging ungefähr
fünf Minuten,
dann wurde ich so begrüßt.
Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Hier nochmal in Zeitlupe
und ran gesumt.
Grandios, oder?
Das ist die PS5 Next Gen Experience.
Das ist ja fast wie Battlefield 2042.
Da hast ihr auch die ganzen
Low Level of Detail Models gehabt
am Anfang.
Scheiße hier.
Da ist alles normal.
Guckt mal ein bisschen weiter weg
da hinten auf den Tower.
Hey, das ist ja fast
wie im ersten Warzone.
Im ersten Warzone.
Wer erinnert sich noch
an den Flughafen?
Flughafen hast du drauf gesumt
und dann wurde erst mal
das Gebäude reingeladen.
Pixelmatsch.
Wie soll man da zum Beispiel
jetzt wen raussnipen?
Und sowas, das passiert
nicht einmal,
das passiert auch ständig.
Habt ihr es hier wieder gesehen?
Auch da hat das Gesicht
nicht richtig geladen.
Immer wieder hat dieses Game
irgendwelche Grafikfehler.
Auch auf der Map,
dass teilweise die Dinge
hier total überlappen.
Es geht mir alles auf den Sack.
Es kommt mir alles vor
wie ein absolutes
visuelles Downgrade.
Es fühlt sich
und es spielt sich
und es sieht scheiße aus.
Da hinten tolle Grafik, Max, oder?
Ich finde es so toll.
Es macht so Freude.
Es macht mir so Spaß.
Leute geben konstant BM.
Ja, da haben irgendwelche Leute,
irgendwelche Entwickler verkackt.
Die fragt mich nicht,
wie das heißt.
Irgendwelche Reflection Probes
oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Verkackt.
42 Shit dafür,
dass es so kaputt ist.
Dann spielt man das hier
und es ist noch viel kaputter.
Es ist so kaputt.
Guckt euch das an.
Guckt euch die Frame Drops an.
Das kann nicht deren Ernst sein.
Ein Viertel der Lobbys sieht so aus.
Und warum?
Wahrscheinlich wegen SBMM
oder weil die Server einfach scheiße sind.
Aber ich vermute,
es liegt an Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Du suchst eine Lobby, ja?
Du hast fünf bis zehn Minuten
Matchmaking-Zeit
und dann kriegst du
eine High-Ping-Lobby
mit einem Ping von über 50.
Spiel ich Battlefield,
ich habe einen Ping
von neun Millisekunden
oder bis zu elf Millisekunden, ja?
Es liegt nicht an meinem Internet.
Es liegt am Dreck
Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Und das per Design,
weil das irgendwer so haben will.
Sie verdienen es alle,
ihren Job zu verlieren.
Am besten gleich ihr Leben noch dazu.
Nein, wirklich.
Jetzt will er es aber wissen, Alter.
Übertreib mal nicht.
Jetzt übertreib es halt mal nicht
so extrem, Mann.
Frage mich,
was für Missgeburten dahinterstecken
für ein Game zu machen.
Zum Teufel.
Jetzt ist aber gut, ey.
Frage mich, warum ich hier nicht
aus der Drohne rausgehe
oder mich bewege.
Ich kann es nicht.
Ich bin festgebackt
ab dem Moment, wo ich
in die Drohne reingegangen bin.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich kann überhaupt
gar nichts mehr machen.
Das sind Game-Breaking-Glitches
und Bugs in der Welt.
Und sie gehören gefixt.
Also das hatte ich auch,
das hatte ich auch,
dass ich am Anfang,
ihr kennt ja diese Pre-Game-Lobby,
wo man dann bis alles geladen ist.
Und ich bin einfach mal
in der Pre-Game-Lobby
nicht dort geblieben,
wo man spawnt,
sondern die Leute werden ja
immer ein bisschen verteilt
gespawnt auf der Map
und können sich dann irgendwie
30 Sekunden, 40 Sekunden
lang killen,
bevor das Game losgeht.
Ich bin einfach mal
nur geradeaus gerannt
in dieser Pre-Game-Lobby.
Einfach nur geradeaus
und irgendwann bin ich
in irgendeiner unsichtbaren Wand gestuckt
und konnte nicht mal weiterlaufen.
Aber immerhin,
ich bin an dem Flugzeug gespawnt
und die Runde ging normal los.
Das Video ist, glaube ich,
nicht gelb.
Das liegt daran,
weil das hier hinten die Zone ist.
Und ich kann das insofern schon nachvollziehen.
Das Game ist ziemlich unüberlegt
und kaputt an vielen Stellen.
Aber das ist tatsächlich wieder das Gleiche
wie bei Modern Warfare 2019.
Da war der Multiplayer,
fand ich auch schon ziemlicher Kack
und der Rest auch nicht sonderlich toll.
Und Warzone hat es gerettet.
Ich gehe davon aus,
es wird wieder so sein.
Warzone wird das retten.
Der Multiplayer ist für den Arsch.
Den Multiplayer kannst du eigentlich nur verwenden,
um ein bisschen deine Sachen zu anlocken.
Und der Rest wird wahrscheinlich wieder einschlagen.
Ich meine, es wurde ja ein paar Sachen
tatsächlich verkompliziert,
nenne ich es jetzt mal.
Es gibt jetzt ja zum ersten Mal
ein richtiges,
kann man es richtiges nennen,
aber es gibt ja zum ersten Mal
ein Inventarsystem.
Das gab es ja im ersten Warzone nicht.
Du hast jetzt ja ein Inventar.
Du kannst jetzt quasi
zu den gegnerischen Rucksäcken gehen,
dort reinschauen
und dann das rausnehmen,
was du willst.
So Geld, Looten, Granaten,
Looten und so was.
Also,
das gab es ja vorher nicht.
Vorher hat es halt das Problem,
dass du immer die falschen Sachen
vom Boden aufgehoben hast.
Das ist tatsächlich, finde ich,
ganz gut geworden.
Aber es wird nach wie vor so sein,
Leute,
Warzone ist so ein gewisses Phänomen.
Es läuft schon irgendwie fast von selbst.
Es gibt zigtausend Content Creator,
die Warzone machen.
Es gibt ganz viele Leute,
die Warzone spielen.
Und letztendlich ist Warzone 1
schon so erfolgreich gewesen,
weil es halt eben der casualigste,
aber immer noch ganz,
ganz gut gemachte Battle-Royale-Shooter ist.
Vor allem mit einer großen Marke dahinter,
mit massig Geld dahinter,
viel Updates dahinter.
Und das wird bei Warzone 2
wieder genauso sein.
In diesem Game Skins kaufen
und damit dieses Game am Leben erhalten
und dafür sorgen,
dass das Businessmodell
funktioniert.
Guck, hier sieht man das Inventar.
Die verdient es die am besten gleich mit.
Ich kriege so das Kotzen.
Je mehr ich darüber nachdenke,
desto mehr kriege ich das Kotzen.
Es macht mich so aggressiv.
Wisst ihr,
ich habe ein Video gemacht,
also hätte er das nicht gesagt,
man hätte es auch gehört,
wo ich mich darüber beschwert habe,
dass die Call of Duty Community
Battlefield kaputt machen.
Das stimmt so nicht ganz.
Die macht das ganze Gaming kaputt.
Die Leute,
die dieses Game unterstützen
und aktiv spielen werden,
sie machen Gaming als Ganzes kaputt,
indem so eine Scheiße durchgeht.
Ja, auch dieser Server,
diese Lobby hier ist wieder im Arsch.
Wie ständig die Lobbys im Arsch sind.
Ein aus fünf,
wenn nicht ein aus vier Matches,
stürzt ab.
Diese Dreckskartoffelserver.
Und warum?
Weil die Leute,
die dieses Game machen,
sparen, wo es nur geht.
Sie verdienen.
Ich glaube mal,
ich weiß nicht,
ob es wirklich am Sparen liegt.
Sicherlich,
sicherlich auch.
Ja, die werden nicht mehr ausgeben.
Aber ich glaube ganz im Ernst,
ich glaube,
die sind einfach erstens
an vielen Stellen
ziemlich unfähig mittlerweile.
Und das nächste ist,
es muss schon
schnell gehen.
Man hat keine Zeit,
weil letztendlich geht es da
um massig Kohle
und sie haben gelernt.
Und da muss ich ihm insofern
schon ein bisschen recht geben,
weil sie haben gelernt,
die Leute fressen und spielen
auch den unfertigen,
kaputtenden Kram.
Und wenn du das weißt,
gibt sie dir auch keine Mühe mehr.
Warum solltest du dir
auch Mühe geben,
wenn du jetzt die Auswahl hast?
Ich baue eine Sache ein
und danach hast du die,
also du baust was ein,
danach hast du die Wahl,
ich entwickle an was Neuem
oder aber ich polish jetzt das,
was ich vorher eingebaut habe.
Ja, warum sollte man das polishen,
wenn es die Leute auch so fressen?
Da ist schon was dran.
Zumal man mit dem anderen
dann wieder Geld verdienen kann.
Die geben sich,
die geben sich halt einfach
keine Mühe mehr,
weil es die Leute fressen.
Da ist schon was dran.
Und sie müssen trotzdem
noch sparen, sparen.
Eskalieren halt komplett hier.
Alles, was man einsparen kann,
wird eingespart.
Und wenn es die
gottverdammten Server sind,
die wichtig sind,
damit das Spiel vernünftig läuft.
Scheiß drauf.
Einsparen.
Damals im Original-MW2
da hat man sich auch noch
die Mühe gemacht
und die scheiß Lizenzen gekauft,
damit die Waffen richtig heißen.
War das,
hießen die wirklich,
die hießen doch auch schon
in MW1 nicht richtig, oder?
In MW1 2019.
Im originalen MW1 hießen die richtig.
2009 oder so.
MW2, MW1 2019.
Im originalen MW2,
ja, da hießen die richtig.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Wisst ihr,
ich hab da,
ich hab da zwei,
ich hab da zwei Vermutungen,
warum das so ist
mit den Waffenbezeichnungen.
Das erste ist,
also das erste ist das,
was er auch sagt,
das könnte sein,
dass man sich das Geld sparen will.
Aber das glaube ich gar nicht mal.
Wisst ihr, was ich eher glaube?
Ich glaube, die wollen nicht
mit der Waffenlobby
in Verbindung gebracht werden.
So nach dem Motto,
also die wollen den Shitstorm vermeiden,
dass irgendjemand sagt,
sie hätten die Waffenlobby supportet
mit,
mit Geld.
Vielleicht ist es,
vielleicht ist es eine Kombination aus beidem.
Ich find's aber auch blöd,
dass die Waffen keine richtigen Namen haben.
Ich mein, Lachmann,
was soll der Scheiß?
Warum heißt das Ding nicht Heckler und Koch MP5?
Sondern Lachmann,
irgendwas,
7, 6,
sonst was
oder Lachmann-Sub
und sowas.
Das ist bescheuert.
Ich mein, Lachmann ist ja wenigstens irgendwie noch,
gewisserweise,
das hört sich so halbwegs deutsch an.
Aber,
ja,
aber,
ganz im Ernst,
warum heißt das Ding nicht Heckler und Koch MP5,
anstatt Lachmann-Sub?
Spart man sich jetzt auch,
deswegen haben wir drei Gewehre namens Lachmann.
Ich könnte...
Da kommt's schon,
Lachmann.
... so kotzen.
Ich könnte kotzen,
wenn ich daran denke,
dass es Leute gibt,
die, indem sie Skins kaufen,
dieses Business-Modell auch noch unterstützen.
Es macht mich so wütend,
es macht mich so traurig.
Ohne Scheiß jetzt.
Es kommt mir so vor,
als ob die sich hier bei COD vorgenommen haben,
sich mit denen bei Battlefield einen Wettstreit zu liefern,
wäre die eigene Reise...
Aber ich dachte,
der Spieler auf dem PC spielt...
Spieler auf der PS5,
ne,
hat er vorhin gesagt.
... schneller in Grund und Boden stampfen kann.
Das kann doch nicht deren Ernst sein.
Sogar fucking Hazard Zone in 2042 hat mir mehr Spaß gemacht als das hier.
Das hier ist für mich das schlechteste AAA-Game,
was ich jemals gespielt habe.
Und ich habe viele schlechte AAA-Games gespielt.
Aber Warzone 2...
Hey,
Free Game,
nicht beschweren hier.
Free Game.
Toppt echt alles.
Es toppt sogar fucking Fallout 76 noch.
Es ist kaputter als Fallout 76 zum Release.
Das will schon echt was heißen.
Das muss man erstmal schaffen.
Nebenbei...
Wisst ihr, das ist ja so eines der Standardsachen,
was Leute gerne von solchen Spielen sagen,
so nach dem Motto,
warum regst du dich auf?
Es ist doch kostenlos.
Du musst es doch nicht spielen und sowas.
Das mag ja alles sein.
Es steht ja keiner mit der Pistole hinter dir und sagt dir,
du musst das Game jetzt spielen.
Aber wenn du es spielst und da in dem Spiel Sachen drin sind,
die dich abfacken,
dann facken die dich ab.
Es ist egal,
ob du dafür bezahlt hast oder ob es kostenlos ist.
Hast du dir einen Aim-Assist für Konsolenspiele angestellt?
Ja,
das ist super,
super heftig in MW2.
Gibt es auch dieses Video,
wo der Typ sich dreht
und quasi automatisch dann sein Fadenkreuz am Gegner stickt,
ohne dass er richtig seinen Controller bewegt.
Ja,
der Aim-Assist ist ultra heftig.
Das Sounddesign von diesem Game ist auch echt komisch.
Damals original MW2,
du konntest sogar ohne...
Wisst ihr,
wisst ihr,
was eigentlich richtig OP wäre?
Noch,
noch OPer als auf der PS5 zu spielen?
Wenn man mit Kronos auf dem PC spielt,
dann hast du auf dem PC bessere Performance,
bessere Auflösung,
bessere,
besseres alles.
Plus du hast den Aim-Assist und kannst deine Maus verwenden.
Die Pros spielen Konsole.
Naja,
wir spielen Controller,
nicht unbedingt Konsole.
Aber,
aber total,
also,
das müsste doch mal richtig OP sein,
oder?
Kronos am PC,
nicht an der PS5.
Du hast alles gehört.
Hier in diesem Game,
du kannst,
was weiß ich,
wie viele Audioeinstellungen durchgehen.
Es wird nicht besser.
Das stimmt.
Du hörst,
du hörst in dem,
das stimmt tatsächlich,
du hörst den War-Sound total viel,
aber nicht das,
worauf es ankommt.
Manchmal hörst du nicht,
dass einer hinter dir die Treppe hochläuft.
Das ist ganz weird.
Der,
der Sound ist wirklich ganz weird.
Und,
und,
weird champ.
Wie scheiße.
Und du hörst trotzdem nichts.
Teilweise kann einer fünf Meter neben dir stehen und schießen.
Du hörst es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht,
was in diesem Spiel kaputt ist,
dass das so ist,
aber es ist leider so.
Es geht mir so auf den Sack.
Es geht mir alles in diesem Game auf den Sack.
Aber das geht mir auch nochmal ganz besonders auf den Sack.
Du wirst genötigt,
mit Hetze.
Der arme Sack, ja.
Und es klingt scheiße.
Apropos scheiße.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
wie man den A10 so sehr wie in diesem Game verkacken kann.
Der war doch in Warzone 1 mal gut.
Was?
Was haben die damit angestellt?
Der ist jetzt noch mehr Ping-Pong-Kanone als...
Äh,
A10?
Ist das,
ist das der,
äh,
Airstrike?
Der B11 in GTA.
Der ist sogar schlechter,
als der BF2042 A10 im Portal-Modus,
wenn man da richtig schießt.
Genau.
Und der braucht gefühlt zehn Treffer,
um den Infanteristen zu töten.
Das kann doch nicht deren Ernst sein.
Der A10 ist so...
Benzel,
Dankeschön.
14 Monate Subscription.
Massive.
Nice.
H었어요,
dass bist du hier gerade?
Ja.
Genau in diesem Games-Game.
Allgemein kommen mir die Killstreaks ziemlich nutzlos vor.
Außer der Drohne...
Äh,
ja,
scout Data Unsighted Demonstrativen
UV-Streak Darthóp total oft.
Ich weiß nicht ob das ein Bug war am Anfang.
Vielleicht sagt er das jetzt auch.
Ähm,
gefühlt in jeder zweiten Kiste hatte ich eine UV.
...die Drohne,
ist halt einfach Godlike.
Und warum?
Weil sie es einem deutlich schwieriger gemacht haben,
an die eigenen Klassen zu kommen.
Die konnte man sich in Warzone 1 ja noch bequem im Shop kaufen.
Und zwar hat man...
nicht mehr. Du kannst jetzt, du, im Shop
kannst du erstmal nur Primary-Waffen kaufen
und Gadgets und sowas.
Hatste dein Zeug. Das war wunderbar
an Warzone. Das war das, was Warzone gut gemacht hat.
Man hatte zwar am Anfang so...
Macht, macht aber Warzone 2
ein bisschen Battle Royale-iger.
Zumindest den anderen
ähnlicher. ...eine Random-Phase, wo man halt
Loot gesammelt hat und dann nicht unbedingt das hatte,
was man haben wollte. Aber spätestens so
ab der Mitte der Runde hatte man eigentlich
genau das Setup, was man spielen wollte
und konnte dann damit vernünftig spielen
und alles war gut. Nein, hier muss man
jetzt diesen PvE-Dreck spielen, um
an die Klassen zu kommen. Ja, den, den ich am Anfang
gezeigt hab. Nicht bis zu dem Punkt mit dem Juggernaut,
aber das Stückchen davor mit dieser
NPC-Basis, sehr wohl. Gratulation.
Ganz toll. Und dann gibt's eine
Reihe von Abwürfen während der Runde.
Die könnte man dann einsammeln,
aber die kann halt jeder einsammeln. Ja.
Und das war's. Shop, kannst
vergessen. Kannst dir nur deine eigenen Waffen kaufen.
Aber nicht die Perks. Und ohne Perks
bist du auf der Drohne. Also bist du immer auf der Drohne.
Denk da mal drüber nach.
Entweder bist du dauerhaft auffällig, weil du dauerhaft
auf der Drohne bist oder musst diese PvE-Kacke
spielen, um nicht mehr auffällig zu sein,
bist aber währenddessen total auffällig und
wirst wahrscheinlich von einem anderen Team weggepusht und umgebracht,
während du die PvE-Kacke machst.
Hä?
Gratulation. Völlig
hirnrissig. Genauso hirnrissig wie diese
komischen neuen Wander... Dem konnte ich jetzt
irgendwie nicht ganz folgen. ...Wanderhoden, die sie eingeführt haben.
Was soll das denn bitte? Das hat sich
doch bestimmt irgend so ein kleiner Wanderhoden
bei denen bei COD ausgedacht, der das
ganz toll findet. Oh, die Zone
splittet sich in drei Teile und
dann wandert... Ja, das fand ich auch erstmal sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftig. ...zur Mitte und machen
eine Zone, ha ha ha, und
dann wird die kleiner und dann wandert die in eine
zufällige Richtung, ha ha ha.
Was soll das bringen? Wer hat darum gebeten?
Niemand. Es bringt auch
nichts. Vielleicht soll es ja das Campen verhindern.
Es erreicht aber doch das absolute Gegenteil.
Denk da mal drüber nach.
Da sitzen dann welche am Rand durch Zufall
genau da, wo die Zone hinwandert.
Ey, das ist eines der Sachen,
die mir bei Battle Royale prinzipiell auf den
Sack geht. Dass du einfach
rumliegen kannst die ganze Zeit.
Ich erinnere nur mal da dran,
hab ich schon ein paar Mal erzählt, ich hab mal irgendwann
den Fehler gemacht und hab ein koreanisches
PUBG-Tournament geguckt.
Wo es auch nicht irgendwie um
Kills oder irgendwie sonst was
ging, sondern es ging wirklich da drum, wer am Ende
die Runde gewinnt. Und am Ende die Runde
haben diejenigen gewonnen, das war glaube ich ein Dreier oder ein Vierer,
ich glaub sogar ein Viererteam.
Dreier oder Viererteam?
So, und die haben
legit die ganze Runde rumgezockt,
umgegammelt, im Gras, an irgendeiner
Mauer. Und am Ende
haben sie dann zwei Kills gemacht und haben gewonnen.
Und ich sag euch, die Caster,
die das casten mussten, die haben versucht
Hype zu generieren.
Es war aber wirklich cringe anzugucken.
Die haben dir dann
sonstige Dinge erzählt, so
It's getting intense, it's getting intense.
Und in Wirklichkeit hat irgendein Typ grad mal den Feuermodus
gewechselt oder sowas.
Es war nix, es ist einfach
eine Viertelstunde nix passiert.
Also.
Das war glaube ich keine sinnvolle Sache,
das tun die so zu hart, es war wirklich kein Bescheid.
Ja, also, das ist halt so ein Ding,
was ich an Battle Royale allgemein ein bisschen blöd finde.
Was halt im Zweifelsfall
an der Map liegen kann, ist, dass du am Ende
einen Kill absnacken kannst.
Auf der anderen Seite, man kann das auch wirklich
aktiv spielen.
Guckt euch die ganzen Warzone-Streamer an,
ich hab öfters mal bei Schucks damals reingeguckt,
gut, der spielt auch Konsole, macht aber keinen Unterschied.
Leute, die spawnen,
also die springen vom Flugzeug ab,
killen erstmal acht Leute, weil
es halt meist ein Superstore oder irgendwas war,
wo halt viel los war.
Keine Ahnung, Caldera hab ich nie gespielt.
Und dann sind die
permanent am Rennen und Flitzen
über die Map und am Leute killen.
Also du kannst das schon äußerst aktiv
und fast schon
TDM-like spielen.
Musst halt auch ein bisschen was
auf die Reihe kriegen, ja.
Aber du kannst halt auch abschimmeln bis zum Schluss.
Wobei ich das halt langweilig als Fuck finde,
weil du hast vielleicht dann am Ende
Rundenwind, aber du hast halt
30 Minuten rumgelegt.
Den perfekten Camper-Spot,
weil alle anderen Teams genau zu ihnen kommen müssen.
Weil das ja die Richtung ist,
die am längsten aus dem Gas raus ist.
Und dann können die Leute, die da hinkommen,
perfekt abcampen. Und so gewinnt dann
am Ende ein Team durch Zufall,
einfach weil sie am richtigen Spot waren.
Allein schon diese Runden, die ich durch diesen Scheiß
verloren habe, es geht mir so
auf den Sack, es ist so zum Kotzen
und es ist so traurig und hirnrissig.
Die bewährte Lösung ist,
dass es zur Mitte kleiner wird, das ist fair.
In der Mitte möchte niemand sein und alle werden
rausgetrieben, aber nö. Ich hoffe, das Video
hat euch gefallen.
Hopp, Video.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt gelernt
in dem Video, er findet es scheiße.
Mit vielen Punkten, die ich so auch
nachvollziehen kann.
Ob man jetzt den Entwicklern wünschen muss,
dass sie sterben, naja,
man kann es auch übertreiben.
Aber unterm Strich, ich kann es gut verstehen, dass es ihm keinen Bock macht.
DMZ ist Underrated.
DMZ habe ich tatsächlich genau eine Runde
gespielt und war höchst verwirrt,
was Bots sind und was
Gegner sind. Auf einmal habe ich
einen Bot gekillt und es war ein Gegner.
Was du ja am Killfeed siehst, ja.
Also, hä, was war das jetzt?
So, was können wir uns sonst angucken?
Was haben wir denn hier noch Schönes?
Reale Irrsinn.
Installing macOS on a Microsoft.
Ah, 22 Minuten, Alter.
Wir können das, wir können das, wir können das mal überspringen.
Skippen.
Hochzeiten sind sein Job.
So arbeitet ein selbstständiger, freier Trauredner.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
das lässt man irgendwelche Leute machen, die man kennt.
Die dürfen da eben halt die großen Reden
schwingen.
Gut, mal davon abgesehen, ich würde nicht heiraten.
Also, das heißt,
ich habe das Problem
ursprünglich nicht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn,
dann würde ich es doch jemandem machen lassen, den ich kenne.
Unabhängig davon,
ob der es gut kann oder nicht.
Ist dann wenigstens irgendwas Persönliches.
Sag mal, irgendwie ist fast alles,
was wir empfohlen kriegen, nichts, was mich
interessiert. Wir gucken die falschen
Videos, Leute. Oder der YouTube
Algorithmus verkackt. Kann auch sein.
Aber sonst so irgendwas.
Die Katastrophe namens Metaverse.
I made the world's smallest server rack.
Okay, das gucken wir uns mal schnell an, was
er da gebaut hat.
Alter Resident Sleeper.
But you have to have a fairly large space to set it up.
It generates a lot of heat and it can be quite noisy.
So that's why I built this.
The world's smallest server rack.
And it fits right in.
Okay, mit so einem.
SSD Dings.
Die Displays, die Displays kenne ich.
Das ist so ein 0815 Standard Display.
SSD 1360.
Sowas in der Richtung ist das wahrscheinlich.
So eine Art Display.
Eines der Standard Dinger.
Put it on my desk alongside a drink
or cup of coffee.
It runs docker, so it can handle
a number of containers.
People have asked me to add an SSD.
Also es ist im Prinzip ein 3D, ist das ein 3D?
Ja, es ist ein 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse.
And when I made one up for an SSD,
then people have asked me to add a UPS.
Okay, mal eine komplett bescheuerte Frage.
Aber was ist der Sinn überhaupt davon?
Letztendlich ist da ein Raspberry Pi drinne.
Warum muss ein Raspberry Pi in so ein fettes Gehäuse?
Beziehungsweise in so ein fettes Rack?
Es ist ja kein Rack.
Kannst das Ding dann mal richtig rein und raus machen.
Also was ist der Sinn davon?
Weil du kannst ein Raspberry Pi einfach
in ein Alu-Gehäuse stecken,
dann bleibt der kühl,
alles ist gut
und im Zweifelsfall machst du halt eine SSD dran
und stellst ihn drauf.
Kannst du theoretisch unten noch mit irgendeinem
Tesa-Powerstrip dran machen.
Sieht nice aus. Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Die LED-Anzeige ist auch
total unsinnig.
Die braucht auch niemand.
Sieht nämlich so aus, als steht da die IP drauf
und, ich muss mal kurz mal ein bisschen...
IP steht drauf,
RAM-Usage, Disk-Usage,
Temperaturen, braucht kein Mensch.
Wenn ich wissen will, wie man Raspberry Pi
im Keller für eine Temperatur hat, gehe ich einfach
bei SSH drauf und gucke das. Oder ich habe irgendein
Monitoring, was das überwacht.
Also, es sieht cool aus,
sinnvoll ist es nicht, zumal
du das Ganze auch auf jeden Fall nicht aktiv
kühlen musst.
Mit dem passenden Case.
Aber es sieht cool aus.
Das muss man ihm lassen.
Okay, das ist cool.
Der hat eine Batterie mit drinne.
Okay, wenn man eine Batterie da
irgendwie noch, irgendeinen Akku noch mit reinlegt,
dann ist es tatsächlich so,
das würdest du schwierig
in so ein Raspberry Pi-Case bekommen.
Ja, das müsstest du dann irgendwie
draußen dran kleben und...
Ja, das hat vielleicht doch seinen Sinn.
So, lasst uns mal gucken.
Okay.
Ja, 3D gedruckt.
Ob er den Lüfter braucht,
ich weiß nicht, ich glaube ein paar
Kühllöcher hätten es getan, ja.
Oben, dass die warme Luft raus kann,
unten, dass kalte Luft reinkommt.
Also, wenn das Ding jetzt nicht gerade auf 100% läuft,
gerade der Raspberry Pi 4 wird halt,
wenn er CPU-Last zieht,
also, wenn er CPU-Last hat, relativ schnell warm.
Aber...
ob man wirklich aktiv kühlen muss,
ich bin mir da sehr unschlüssig.
... GPS, because it uses these Pogo-Pins
to connect to the Pi's GPO-Pins...
Aber es sieht halt cool aus.
... because of the jumper to hook it up
to the Pi's USB-Ports.
Das hat mich dazu gefühlt,
alle drei auf einander zu montieren,
und die Lösung, die mir kam,
ist eine Art Rack-Mounting-Klöscher,
obwohl diese in Größen nicht für einen Raspberry Pi passen,
also habe ich mir eine eigene designt.
Ich habe den Rack in Fusion 360 designt,
damit er ein wenig wie ein Server-Rack aussieht,
der für ein typisches Home-Lab genutzt wird.
Da bin ich ja viel zu unfähig,
für eigene Sachen für einen 3D-Drucker zu designen.
Hat das jemand von euch schon mal gemacht?
Ich druck ab und zu mit meinem 3D-Drucker Zeug aus,
beispielsweise letztens Clips.
Clips für den Herd,
für die Dunstabzugshaube über dem Herd.
Also für solche Sachen ist der Dreh-Drucker
schon recht praktisch.
Aber selbst Sachen Design bin ich zu pp'ger für.
It's got a tinted acrylic swing door on the front
and tinted acrylic side panels.
Oh, der Chat ist high IQ, wie immer.
The top, bottom and back are all solid panels,
with the back having a cable entry point
and the top having a 40mm fan for cooling.
Inside we've got space for three racks,
so that we don't have to worry about the cooling.
In the back, we've got a 40mm fan for cooling.
Inside we've got space for three racks,
one for the Pi, one for the UPS
and one for the SSD.
Die Perspektive sieht irgendwie nicht richtig aus, oder?
Die Perspektive, das sieht viel zu breit aus hier.
I'm also going to mount an OLED-Display alongside the Pi
to provide some stats on resource usage on the server.
With the design done,
I 3D-printed the parts in black PLA.
Ja, das ist ein 3D-gedrucktes Gehäuse,
machen wir mal weiter.
Also das Gehäuse hat bestimmt 18 Stunden gedruckt, ja?
So those are all the components
and the housing made up.
Now we just need to add the racks to it
to hold the electronics.
Ach so, ach stimmt, das ist ja nicht am Block,
das ist ja einzelne Dinger.
Das geht vielleicht sogar.
Aber es ist relativ viel,
das hat auf jeden Fall eine Weile gedruckt.
As this can be plugged in or removed
using a USB-Cable or jumper.
Man kann auch einfach, jetzt mal seriously,
man kann auch einfach eine stinknormale SATA-SSD nehmen
und dann mit einem USB-Adapter
oder eine USB-SSD.
Was wahrscheinlich die einfachere Variante ist
als mit so einem Ding
und wahrscheinlich auch noch billiger.
Und performance-technisch
macht es beim Raspberry Pi keinen Unterschied.
Ah, das hält ein bisschen.
Ja, das hält ein bisschen.
Also ich habe für den Raspberry Pi
auch so eine Mini-USV.
Das ist allerdings mit so einer,
ich zeige euch das mal.
Wie heißen diese Batterien,
die in 8, 7,
die auch in E-Zigaretten drin sind.
Akku, 8, 10, ja die Dinger.
Da war der Stream gerade gelaggt.
Ah, Vodafone macht wieder Dinger.
Also ich habe so eine Raspberry Pi,
Mini-Raspberry Pi-USV
mit so einem Akku drin.
UPS.
Äh, jetzt sieht es anders aus.
Lin-schu-gwin-gum.
Ah, alles klar.
Sieht sowas hier.
Sowas hier in der Richtung ist das,
was ich habe.
Sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
Machst eine Batterie rein,
steckst den Raspberry Pi an USB
und gut ist, easy.
Sieht halt nicht so cool aus
und nicht so schön quadratisch wie bei ihm.
Sieht quasi so ein bisschen aus.
So hier.
So sieht das, so sieht das aus.
Ziemlich, ziemlich ähnlich, ja.
Ja, dieses Teil.
So, so ähnlich sieht das, sieht das aus.
Da, man schließt den Raspberry Pi einfach per USB an.
Machst auf der einen Seite die Stecker,
einen Stecker dran, auf der anderen Seite,
also nicht einen Stecker, hier machst du USB in
und hier machst du USB out.
Und das schaltet halt um, wenn das ausfällt.
Geht genauso gut.
Sieht halt nicht so stylisch aus wie das Ding.
The godown's about an hour or two.
It can handle a continuous output
of up to 3 amps, so it'll have no trouble
supplying power to the additional equipment
and the SSD as well.
Hm.
Das kann man so nicht zwangsläufig sagen.
Der Raspberry Pi hat nicht die besten,
den besten Output, was, also, ähm, also hat, glaube ich,
nur maximal 750 Milliampere oder sowas für die,
oder 650 für die USB-Outputs.
Das reicht für einige SSDs nicht.
Und das führt dann meistens nicht dazu,
dass es einfach nicht geht, sondern dass es random
immer mal wieder abkackt
oder die Platte read-only wechselt und sowas.
Also da muss man gucken.
Also wer Stabilitätsprobleme mit seinem Raspberry Pi hat
und das Ding über einen USB-SSD betreibt,
der sollte mal in die Logs gucken, ob die Platte nicht read-only geht
und wenn sie das macht, dann wahrscheinlich,
weil die Platte nicht genug Strom bekommt.
Und selbst wenn es nicht read-only ist, einfach,
wenn es Errors bei der Platte gibt oder bei der SSD gibt,
dann liegt das höchstwahrscheinlich daran,
dass die Platte nicht mit genug Saft versorgt werden kann
aus den USB-Ports vom Raspberry Pi.
Das UPS ist ein bisschen komplizierter,
weil es mit den Pogo-Pins ist,
also kann man es nicht einfach unter der Platte einschalten.
Es muss physisch auf den Boden der Platte eingeschraubt werden,
also muss ich diese beiden Racks kombinieren.
Ist aber eine schöne Variante, ist schön kompakt
und sieht gut passend aus.
Ist schöner als so ein USB-Ding, was daneben hängt.
Du kannst den Output erhöhen, aber musst du beim Raspberry Pi 4 nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das musstest du nur bei den alten.
Bei dem 4er ist es so, dass du maximal über die Ports
so und so viel ziehen kannst
und da bringt dir auch eine Config nichts.
Und das reicht für einige SSDs nicht.
Zum Beispiel für die ganzen SanDisk-USB-Dinger,
SanDisk Ultra und hast du nicht gesehen, USB 3.
SSDs oder 3.2 SSDs, USB 3.2 SSDs, reicht das nicht.
Oftmals tritt es dann auch in Kombination auf,
wenn du beispielsweise noch was anderes angeschlossen hast an USB,
dass der maximale Output, den du hast, an USB-Ports nicht reicht.
Mit den High-IQ-Dingern.
Sieht schon recht clean aus, gebe ich zu.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz schick.
Hättest du selbst eine Idee, wenn es um einen Konsolenserver
für alle Geräte in einem Rack geht?
Ja, kann ich dir was zu sagen.
Du willst keinen Konsolenserver, oder?
Gut, vielleicht willst du einen Konsolenserver.
Wenn du einen Konsolenserver willst,
dann hast du ein Rechenzentrum mit einem eigenen Technikraum.
Hast du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Du hast wahrscheinlich einfach nur einen Rack,
da stehen mit ein paar Rechnern,
auf die du remote drauf zugreifen können möchtest.
Und du hast wahrscheinlich auch keine Probleme,
wenn du dort hinlaufen musst und VGA und USB anstöpseln musst.
Dann kaufst du dir nämlich einfach bei eBay
so eine, ähm, wie heißen diese Dinger?
Spider? Ne, wie heißen die Teile?
Ja, Spider, nicht Speeder.
Spider.
Alter, warum ist das so teuer?
What the fuck?
Ich habe meine damals für 95 Euro oder so gekauft.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Den Kram gibt es anscheinend gerade nicht.
Nicht wirklich lieferbar.
Okay, kann sein, dass es aktuell schlicht ergreifend nichts gibt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe eine für 95 Euro
oder irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh gekauft.
Und musst du mal gucken,
ob du irgendwo was Sinnvolles findest, ja?
Das ist dann total simpel.
Du steckst das dran an USB, an VGA.
Hier auf der anderen Seite steckst du das Netzwerk dran.
Und dann gehst du mit dem Browser drauf.
Und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Das Gerät kam irgendwann 2005 oder so auf den Markt.
Ja, das ist uralt.
Wir haben es ja im Stream mal ausprobiert.
Es gibt Firmware-Updates dafür,
dass du mittlerweile ein HTML5-Interface hast.
Du brauchst auch kein Java mehr und sowas.
Aber aktuell ist es anscheinend nicht zu bekommen.
Wie es aussieht.
Musst mal gucken, was es da sonst noch gibt.
Ist aber wahrscheinlich für dich die bessere ...
Ja gut, da muss man halt selbst ein bisschen was bauen.
Kann man bestimmt auch machen.
Ist wahrscheinlich für dich so die bessere Lösung,
als wirklich irgendein Konsolenteil ins Rack zu bauen.
Braucht man daheim eigentlich nicht.
Was wäre denn ein sinnvoller Preis
für ein Raspberry Pi Model 4?
Kann ich aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Ich glaube ...
Die 4-Gigabyte-Variante kostet, glaube ich,
standardmäßig, also das,
was sich der Hersteller mal gedacht hat,
glaube ich, 50 Euro oder so.
Oder 40 sogar nur.
Oder war es die 2-Gigabyte-Variante?
Aber gut, ich meine,
letztendlich ist es egal,
was sich der Hersteller dabei gedacht hat.
Halt die Frage,
was bist du bereit dafür zu bezahlen?
Das ist halt Knappheit.
Schwierig.
Es ist überhaupt schwierig, einen zu bekommen.
Gucken wir mal,
ob die aktuell welche haben.
Ohne, dass du in ihren komischen Raspberry Pi Club musst.
Nö, gibt nix.
Nix lieferbar.
Nix lieferbar hier.
Zum Glück habe ich noch genug hier.
Sowohl Raspberry Pi 4s als auch Zero 2.
Zero W2.
Der Kram ist halt schon
unsinnig teuer.
149 Euro.
Sonst geht es euch auch noch gut.
Alter, ist das teuer.
Meine Güte.
Ich meine, das 2G-Modell, das kann man sich vielleicht noch geben.
Lieferzeit.
Sieben Wochen.
Sieben Wochen. Ernster Film.
Raspberry Pi.
Ja, schwierig.
Da bin ich echt froh, dass ich noch welche habe.
...
Ach, der hat einen Laser-Cutter.
Ja, das muss der erstmal haben, daheim.
Ich meine, wer hat keinen Laser-Cutter daheim?
Cringe.
...
Wozu? Wozu brauche ich ...
Ich verstehe, dass das ein cooles Projekt das und das irgendwie einen gewissen Show-Effekt hat.
Aber der Sinn von einem Magic Mirror erschließt sich mir wenig.
Weil wenn du im Bad bist, hast du eh dein Handy dabei.
das, was du auf einem Magic Mirror anzeigen
lassen kannst, ist ja in der Regel jetzt auch nicht
so super detailreich, dass es dir irgendwie großartig
was bringt. Höchstens
vielleicht irgendwie Temperatur und Wetter oder
sowas, aber das guckst du eh am besten auf dem Smartphone
nach und hast dann auch
Karte mit Wolken und Regen und sowas.
Also ich
glaube, die meisten überschätzen
die Sinnhaftigkeit oder so der Mehrwert eines
Magic Mirrors.
So, weiter, komm.
Wie sieht's denn am Ende aus?
Noctua-Fan, beste.
Moment, der hat einen Lüfter oben und einen Lüfter außen.
Nee, oder?
Ja, die Seite, das war
das alte Gehäuse
mit dem Lüfter an der Seite.
Ja, so ist es doch deutlich schöner.
Vor allem Noctua, leise
Noctua-Lüfter. Ich meine, die Dinger können ja auch nicht
zaubern, ja. Ich meine, sieht ganz
schick aus.
Okay, das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein Mehrwert
von diesem USV-Board.
Wenn man da so zeitgesteuert das Ein- und
Ausschalten mitmachen kann, das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich meine, kann man auch
easy mit einer anderen schaltbaren Steckdosenleiste
machen, ja.
Ja.
Optisch ganz
hübsch, praktisch
vielleicht
teilweise brauchen, tut man sich
wirklich, macht aber was her.
Lass ich mir gefallen. Und ist bestimmt
mit Sicherheit ein sehr schönes Bastelprojekt.
Und es wird einige
Stunden, Tage,
wenn nicht Wochen, gebraucht
haben, bis da was wirklich Gutes bei rausgekommen
ist. Sowas dauert ja immer
länger, als man denkt.
Überlege gerade, einen alten, gebrauchten Server zu holen
für NAS, Medium,
wie der Gabi. Nein, man muss gucken, was
es für einer ist und wie alt es ist,
weil die Dinger sind laut
und die Dinger sind meistens relativ
stromhungrig
und sind auch nicht da gerade für
gut geeignet,
sie daheim stehen zu haben, weil
da ist nichts mit im Idle
irgendwie Lüfter runterdrehen oder sowas.
Gerade wenn du dir alte, beispielsweise
HP-Server oder sowas holst
oder irgendein so ein DL380
Generation,
irgendwas, was gerade günstig auf
Ebay ist, die Dinger sind
groß, laut und verbrauchen viel
Strom. Leistung haben sie
mit Sicherheit genug, weil auch
10 Jahre alte CPUs für die meisten
Sachen ohne Probleme ausreichen, aber die fressen halt
massig Strom.
Sind heiß, sind laut.
Gucken wir mal, was sowas auf Ebay gerade kostet.
Gucken wir mal, irgendwie so ein alter
DL380.
Guck hier, hier kriegst du zum Beispiel
was für 50 Euro.
Aber das hat genug
Leistung. Es frisst halt wirklich ordentlich.
Strom.
Wir machen mal nur sofort Kauf.
Guck mal hier, für 150 Euro.
Noch einen älteren.
Hier kriegst du ein DL380
G5. Okay, das ist...
G5 ist wirklich alt.
G5 ist...
Den würde ich mir nicht mehr kaufen.
Der ist wirklich alt.
Was war denn da drinnen?
Da sind ja noch
Server aus Zeiten, da war ich fast
noch Azubi.
Das ist
uralt, G5.
Ja.
Von wann sind die CPUs?
2008. Ja.
Das ist, wie gesagt, das ist alt.
Das ist ganz alt. Das würde ich nicht mehr kaufen, das Ding.
Das ist zu alt.
Na, gucken wir uns mal das Ding an. Was ist das für einer?
G7. Ja, das ist was.
Das dürfte preis-leistungstechnisch ganz okay sein.
Leistungsmäßig
reicht es auch komplett aus.
Die Dinger sind aber laut.
Da darf man sich da keine Illusion hingeben.
Die Dinger sind laut.
Sag mal, Ebay, please.
Die Dinger sind auch nicht stromsparend.
Ist halt die Frage, ob sich das wirklich lohnt.
Also,
da würde ich ehrlich gesagt
lieber, wenn es so was
in der Richtung sein sollte, ich meine, du kannst dir
irgendeinen HP
Micro-Server oder sowas kaufen.
Gibt es auch ab
679 Euro. Ist halt nicht so super billig,
wie so ein gebrauchtes Ding.
Hat auch keine
außenliegenden Hotswap.
Rahmen?
Nee.
Also, ganz ehrlich, gebrauchte Server.
Vielleicht findest du was halbwegs Neues
günstig, eventuell, aber selbst
heute sind Sachen nicht ausgelegt
für, ja, sowas hier ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Aber wie gesagt, die sind auch heute nicht dafür ausgelegt,
stromsparend und leise zu sein.
Das ist sogar halbwegs modernes Ding hier.
Halbwegs modernes.
Was ist denn da drinne?
Xeon ein.
Ah, da ist ohne CPU. Kann das sein?
Ist der ohne CPU?
Der ist ohne CPU, oder?
Sonst würd's hier irgendwie drinnen stehen.
Ja.
Tjo, also, ich bin ja kein so großer
Fan von gebrauchten Servern von Ebay.
Die macht ja eigentlich
Backup kleines Nass.
Also, ich hab hier meine
Kiste hinten in diesem Miniserver-Raum
stehen und
ich zieh da ab und zu mal die wichtigsten
Dateien drauf und ich mach
dann ganz simpel
Noob-Style an der Ecke.
Externe Platte in den Air-Sync nachts.
Fertig, aus.
Gar kein großes Ding.
So.
Was können wir uns denn jetzt noch geben?
Hier, zeig mal her.
Die Katastrophe namens Metaverse.
Uiuiui.
Okay, Chat, das guck ich mir jetzt mal an.
Was ist das hier?
Raspberry Pi Alternative Mini PC
Home Server Refurbished Battlefield Deal.
Ein Fujitsu Fudro.
Von den Dingen hab ich noch nie was gehört.
...
Der Preis ist schonmal...
...echt okay
Wurde das Zelatenzaun-Video schon geguckt?
Ne.
Was ham man da drin?
Okay.
Das ist....
...low-power-Intel-Plattform.
Das ist... das ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Das ist okay.
Damit reißt ihr keine Bäume aus, ja.
Also die anderen CPUs sind äh...
...die wir uns davor angucken, sind ja natürlich deutlich schneller.
Aber das ist low-power-Intel.
Wahrscheinlich Quadcore, wenn man Glück hat, einen Quadcore.
Mal gucken ob das ein Quadcore ist.
Oder nur ein Dual.
Ja, Quad-Core. Ja, das geht.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich relativ stromsparend.
Also, diese Plattform an sich
braucht
6, 7 Watt Idle.
Und gut, da ist
dann auch ein bisschen mehr dran. Wahrscheinlich braucht das Ding
Idle 11, 12 Watt.
3 Watt Idle.
Das erscheint mir jetzt ein bisschen
sehr wenig. Das ist nicht schlecht.
Kann man sich tatsächlich überlegen.
Finde ich gar nicht mal so übel.
Preislich ist auch in Ordnung.
Also, wenn man mit sowas kleinem
klarkommt, warum nicht?
Ein Raspberry Pi ist natürlich noch ein bisschen kleiner.
Aber ist schon okay. Es hat auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen mehr Rechenleistung als ein Raspberry Pi.
Auch als ein
Vierer. Braucht ein bisschen
mehr Strom wahrscheinlich.
Aber man kann es halt kaufen.
Was? 3 Watt?
Das erscheint mir sehr wenig zu sein.
Also, ich hatte auch mal so
ein Low Power Intel Plattform.
Die gleiche glaube ich sogar.
Es war halt ein S-Rock Board.
Das war kein Board, was explizit für Low Power
gebraucht war. Und das hat glaube ich 6-7 Watt,
wenn ich alle Power-Sachen
Power-Spa-Sachen eingeschaltet habe.
Ich glaube 7 Watt hat das gebraucht.
Mit SSD.
Ohne
Platten. Warum haben Server so
viel Idle-Verbrauch? Also gut, die haben nicht nur
viel Idle-Verbrauch, die haben generell viel Verbrauch.
Weil die nicht dafür gedacht sind, großartig
irgendwie Lüfter runter zu regeln
oder sonstige Sachen zu machen.
Die sind für dauerhaften
Betrieb ausgelegt. Das heißt auch
dauerhafte Lüftung, dauerhafte
Klimaanlage und dementsprechend
ist da halt der Fokus was anderes.
Da legt keiner Wert drauf, dass die
Dinger sich schön runter
tacken, dass die Lüfter runter
drehen, dass das irgendwie Komponenten
verwendet, die wenig Strom verbrauchen.
Das kommt mit der Zeit, muss man sagen,
ist jetzt schon ein bisschen besser geworden.
Ja, also
gerade in der heutigen Zeit gucken natürlich auch
Rechenzentrum-Betreiber drauf.
Auf Stromkosten.
Und Serverhersteller schmücken
sich natürlich auch ganz gerne mit
unsere Servers sind super grün.
Aber das kannst du vergessen bei den älteren Dingern.
Da liegt einfach nicht der
Fokus drauf. Das ist nicht dafür gebaut.
Im Rechenzentrum ist es ja auch
egal, ob das Ding laut ist oder nicht.
Das steht im Keller oder irgendwo
im siebten Stock oder sonst wo
rum und
keinem interessiert es, ob das laut ist.
Oder warm ist. Oder sonst was
ist. Das ist halt einfach da und
arbeitet vor sich hin und
möglichst selten kaputt gehen.
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon mal die Story
erzählt, warum es bei mir auf der Arbeit
kein Rechenzentrum im Keller
gegeben hat? Warum das
Rechenzentrum irgendwie im fünften Stock oder so
gewesen ist? Wasser?
Nee, nee. Ganz kurz
ist auch ganz einfach
erklärt.
Ist ganz einfach erklärt, weil
man hätte die Möglichkeit gehabt,
das Rechenzentrum im Keller zu
machen. Aber
dort hatten irgendwelche Leute vom
Vorstand ihren Parkplatz
und dann hatte man die Auswahl,
gibt man sehr viel Geld aus
und stellt
das Rechenzentrum irgendwie im fünften
Stock oder
kriegen die ihre Parkplätze gestrichen
und man macht das Rechenzentrum im Keller.
Da hat man sich natürlich dafür
entschieden, selbstverständlich gibt man viel Geld
aus und macht das Rechenzentrum im fünften Stock.
Obviously.
Meinung zu Nux als Cluster für
Kubernetes.
Kann man machen?
Aber ich sehe den Anwendungsfall
für einen Home-Kubernetes-Cluster
nicht. Wenn du
üben willst,
mach. Da kannst du
aber auch ein paar VMs nehmen.
Wenn du üben willst, okay.
Ansonsten
würde ich mir hinterdenken, warum du
daheim überhaupt einen Kubernetes-Cluster haben willst.
Hast du schon die neuen
ZigBee-Sticks, die
jetzt auch Sonoff hat mit diesem neuen Chip?
Oder welche hast du da noch dran?
Also ich habe ja noch einen Conbee2,
der ist ja mittlerweile ziemlich
outdated. Ich meine, er funktioniert ohne Probleme
und ich werde den auch so lange weiterverwenden,
bis er mal nicht mehr funktioniert.
Aber die neuen Sticks
mit den neuen Chips sollen ja deutlich besser sein.
Auch was Reichweite
nochmal angeht.
Würdest du TrueNAS als VM laufen lassen?
Oh, oh, oh. Frag das nicht im
FreeNAS-Forum.
Die steinigen dich dort.
Aber ja, natürlich kannst du das als
VM laufen lassen. Aber frag das nicht
im FreeNAS-Forum.
Kannst du dir als nächstes erzählen, dass du das Ding auch nicht
einschalten darfst, bevor es ECC-RAM hat
und solche Geschichten.
Ja, siehste? Bist du eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Ist das die mit 10G?
Warum heißt das eigentlich K8S?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Keine Ahnung.
Weil es eben die Abkürzung für Kubernetes ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum es K8S ist.
Es gibt ja auch K3S.
Das ist ja so quasi so ein Lightwine-Mini-Kubernetes-Kram.
Warum ist das?
Eine 8? Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, warum
da eine 8 dazwischen ist.
Weil es 8 Buchstaben sind?
Ist das wirklich so? Okay.
K-U-B-E-R-N-E-T-E
S
Tatsächlich.
Five Head.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass die 8 für 8
Charakter sind.
So, was kann man sich ansonsten noch angucken?
Zeig mal her.
Die Katastrophe namens Metaverse.
Ja, wir haben uns ja letztens angeguckt,
dass sogar die Leute, die für Meta,
also die, die,
die Entwickler von Metaverse,
dass sie ihr eigenes Produkt nicht gerne verwenden.
Was ja immer ein super, ähm, ja, Hinweis darauf ist,
dass es wohl ein sehr gutes Produkt zu sein scheint,
wenn die Entwickler es selbst nicht verwenden wollen.
Und da gab es ja letztens eine News,
dass die Entwickler den Kram selbst nicht verwendet haben,
verwenden.
Daraufhin hat irgendwie ein Manager rumgeschrieben,
so nach dem Motto, ihr müsst das Produkt lieben,
was ihr entwickelt, und die sollen es gefälligst verwenden.
Ist halt meiner Ansicht nach von der falschen Seite betrachtet.
Die Leute programmieren das, weil sie Geld dafür bekommen.
Nicht, weil das ihre Herzensangelegenheit wäre,
diesen Shit zu programmieren.
Dann würden die was anderes machen.
Und sie finden es wahrscheinlich scheiße.
Und sie haben wahrscheinlich auch schon oft gesagt,
dass es scheiße ist, aber sie wollen es trotzdem haben.
Und man kann es ja keinen zwingen, dazu irgendwas gut zu finden.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Mitte der 2000er gab es ein kleines Browserspiel,
entwickelt vom Jugendprogramm der Daimler AG Mobile Kids,
namens Mokitown.
Mokitown war eigentlich sehr...
Ist das Club Penguin oder wie das hieß?
...ähnlich zu Habbo Hotel.
Nur konnte man hier kein echtes Geld investieren
und mafiöse Strukturen aufbauen.
Stattdessen war Mokitown eher auf das Vermitteln von Kompetenz
im Straßenverkehr fokussiert.
Schwebende Roboter konnten angesprochen werden
und verteilten ein wenig von der Ingame-Währung,
wenn man kurze Fragen zu Verkehrsregeln oder Trivia beantworten konnte.
Wenn man genug von diesem Geld gesammelt hatte...
Ja, und übrigens, wisst ihr, was man zu VR-Chat auch sagen muss?
Die VR-Chat-Entwickler benutzen ihr eigenes Game
und spielen ihr eigenes Spiel.
Was schon mal ein großer Hinweis darauf ist,
dass die Entwickler dahinterstehen
und dass es irgendwie in gewisser Weise auch was ist,
was man eben benutzen will.
Allein schon das ist für mich ein großer Pluspunkt,
wenn die Entwickler ihren eigenen Kram spielen.
... sich neue Verkehrsmittel wie ein Skateboard...
Also freiwillig, nicht weil sie gezwungen werden oder so.
... oder ein Fahrrad kaufen,
mit dem man schneller durch die zahlreichen Räume navigieren konnte.
Auch neue Kleidung, die man mit dem Fahrrad kaufen kann,
Musik für den Walkman oder ein Handy,
mit dem man mit Leuten auf anderen Karten schreiben konnte,
waren im Sortiment.
Mokitown war für mich eine dieser seltenen Erfahrungen,
in denen wirklich alle Sterne richtig standen.
Ich war im richtigen Alter,
um von diesem Konzept komplett begeistert zu werden.
Also ich habe damals MMOs-Crisal gecrindet,
zu Zeiten, als MMOs noch Multiplayer-Spiele waren
und kein Solo-Questen.
Und ich habe jahrelang nichts anderes gemacht.
Und man könnte ja so weit gehen, um zu sagen,
MMOs damals waren ja in gewisser Weise eine Art Metaverse.
Es kann dir ja eh keiner sagen, wo das MMO anfängt
und wo das Metaverse aufhört oder wo das Metaverse anfängt und das MMO aufhört.
Das ist alles sehr schwammig und sehr fließend.
Warum das jetzt auf einmal, na gut, weil der Zuck gesagt hat, dass es so ist,
der neueste Shit sein soll, verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt eh nicht.
Also Online-Welten, wo Leute zusammen kommunizieren und Sachen machen,
gibt es ja schon ewig.
Wie gesagt, ich habe MMOs gespielt.
Ich habe angefangen, MMOs zu spielen Anfang 2000er.
Und das waren auch wirkliche MMOs.
Du bist da mit hunderten Leuten teilweise im PvP-Gebiet rumgelaufen.
Du hast Quests gemacht, PvM-Missionen, Raids, Dungeons-Geschichten.
Mal mit mehr, mal mit weniger Leuten.
Und das ging. Ja, du hattest einen Chat.
Du hattest theoretisch zwar keinen Voice-Chat,
aber du hattest damals relativ viele Leute noch im Teamspeak.
Discord gab es ja noch nicht.
Das war ja damals so.
Das war ja damals auch schon vieles von dem,
was die sich heute unter Metaverse vorstellen.
Das kann ja heute keiner so genau sagen, was man darunter versteht.
Ja, Second Life habe ich den Hype drum nie verstanden,
aber das gab es auch schon.
Wahrscheinlich ist Second Life mehr Metaverse,
als das Facebook-Metaverse je sein wird.
Und außer, dass der Zuck jetzt das irgendwie ausgerufen hat
als das nächste große tolle, tolle Teil.
Und irgendwie keiner so wirklich daran glaubt.
Weil, was man sich da anguckt.
Ich meine, ich wüsste nicht, wozu man es verwenden soll.
Das Einzige, was vielleicht, also wer das vielleicht geil finden könnte,
sind irgendwelche Manager BWL-Business-Leute,
die sich denken, oh ja, Online-Spiele sind mir viel zu kindisch
und viel zu un-Business-Style.
Jetzt haben wir das Metaverse.
Das ist quasi das MMO für Manager.
Weiß ich nicht, was die sich denken.
Ansonsten, egal, hören wir uns mal das Video an.
Egal, ob interessiert an Videospielen oder nicht,
waren hier regelmäßig anzutreffen.
Und es hatte in diesem Kreis, der für mich damals die ganze Welt war,
ein merkbares soziales Gewicht.
Eine teure Garderobe, ein voller Fuhrpark,
beachtenswerte Highscores in den Minispielen
und eine Bekanntheit in dieser kleinen, isometrischen Pixelstadt
hatten nicht nur Bedeutung in diesem einen kleinen Browserfenster,
sondern auch außerhalb, in der Wirklichkeit.
Es war vielleicht im Ansatz sogar vergleichbar
mit den sozialen Auswirkungen von Earthland Realms.
Dem Online-Rollenspiel, das March und ganz Springfield
in einer Folge der Simpsons spielt.
Seit etwa einem Jahr muss ich immer häufiger
an Moki Town zurückdenken und an die Idylle,
die es für mich symbolisiert.
Seit Facebook vor etwas über einem Jahr
seinen Namen in Meta änderte
und den Kurswechsel des Unternehmens
hin zur Entwicklung des ominösen Metaverses verkündete,
komme ich nicht umhin, gewisse Parallelen zu sehen.
Vor acht Jahren, 2014, hat Facebook
den VR-Headset-Hersteller Oculus gekauft.
Ein Deal, der damals noch hauptsächlich
mit der Sorge verbunden war, dass man in Zukunft
einen Facebook-Account bräuchte,
um die Brillen weiter nutzen zu können.
Was von Facebook erst kategorisch ausgeschlossen wurde,
kam dann später trotzdem.
In Wahrheit entpuppt sich diese Übernahme
aber als erster Schritt für eines der teuersten
und seltsamsten Unterfangen im Silicon Valley.
Normalerweise würde man an dieser Stelle
erstmal die Begrifflichkeiten klären,
damit alle im selben Boot sitzen.
Das ist schwierig, Metaverse zu definieren.
Was also ist das Metaverse?
Nur ist die Antwort bei weitem nicht so trivial.
Man kann es gar nicht so wirklich erklären.
Jeder, der etwas damit zu tun hat, behauptet, es zu wissen.
Doch in Wahrheit ist es ein terminologisches Sonnenliegenrennen.
Alle reißen sich um diesen einen Begriff
und wollen, dass das, was sie bauen, bald darin zu verstehen ist.
Man glaubt, dass man es weiß, aber wenn man es erklären soll,
dann weiß man es nicht.
Der Ursprung dieses Begriffs liegt im Science-Fiction-Roman
Snow Crash von 1992.
Dort ist das Metaverse ein virtueller Zufluchtsort
vor der anarchiegeplagten Realität.
Und mehr oder weniger das scheint der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner
von all den umherfliegenden angeblichen Metaversen zu sein.
Ein virtueller Zufluchtsort für alle.
In einem äußerst unkonkreten Werbevideo
zu Metas Horizon Worlds getauftes Metaversum
ist die vielleicht noch greifbarste Aussage ...
Ah, das ist das, wo die Leute alle keine Beine haben.
... virtually hang out in perfect harmony.
Was so gar nicht wie das Internet klingt, das ich kenne.
Nö.
Und was es auch nicht ist, weil das Erste, was passieren wird,
wenn du dich in so einem Game einloggst,
sind die beschreienden Zwölfjährigen oder Leute,
die dir auf den Sack gehen.
... von Schlüsselfiguren wie Mark Zuckerberg
als nichts Geringeres als the next face of the Internet beschrieben.
Ah, der Typ erzählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Und diese Unbestimmtheit, diese Wahrheit,
die diesem Begriff innerwohnt,
ist vielleicht auch seine größte Stärke.
Nur so kann gewährleistet sein, dass jeder,
der finanziell und oder emotional stark
in das aktuelle Internet investiert ist,
glauben kann, dass es eine rosige Zukunft für einen selbst wird.
Doch was Investitionen angeht,
läuft es gerade beim Vorzeigeprodukt Horizon Worlds
von ehemals Facebook alles anders.
Horizon Worlds ist das Game,
was schlechter aussieht als irgendein Wii-Spiel.
Als rosig.
In 2022.
In Oktober hat Meta seinen aktuellen Quartalsbericht vorgelegt.
Und der ist, nun ja, ziemlich katastrophal.
Der Gewinn des Konzerns sank im Vergleich zum Vorjahr um 52 Prozent,
der Umsatz um 4,4 Prozent.
Reality Labs, die Division von Meta,
die für die Entwicklung des Metaverses zuständig ist,
verschlang allein in diesem dritten Quartal
3,67 Milliarden Dollar,
bei einem Umsatz von 285 Millionen Dollar.
Und das liegt nicht allein daran,
dass die Inflation die Kaufkraft verkauft hat,
sondern muss einen großen Teil auch daran,
dass CEO Mark Zuckerberg horrende Summen
in diese eine große Wette steckt.
Und das tut er in einer Geschwindigkeit und Masse,
die Marktanalysten selbst für die Standards des Silicon Valleys
als furchterregend beschreiben.
Im August 2021,
als Meta noch facetimed,
war ein Firmenanteil noch etwas über 380 Dollar wert.
Ganz Facebook als Unternehmen
hatte eine Marktkapitalisierung von über einer Billion Dollar.
Keine amerikanische Billion, eine deutsche Billion.
Mittlerweile sind von dieser 13-stelligen Summe
noch 240 Milliarden übrig.
Da Zuckerbergs eigenes Vermögen
zu einem Großteil auf seinen 350-Millionen-Anteilen
an dieser Aktie aufbaut,
ist auch sein Geldspeicher durch diesen Crash
von 125 Milliarden auf 37 Milliarden Dollar.
Boah, der Arme!
Das ist in Anbetracht geopolitischer Umstände
Der muss ja bald unter die Brücke, Mann!
noch außerordentlich schlecht.
So sehr sogar, dass Meta,
einst auf Platz 6,
mittlerweile nur noch auf Platz 32
der wertvollsten Unternehmen der Welt ist.
Hinter Samsung und Costco.
Und diese Zahlen,
dieses engstirnige Verfolgen dieser unkonkreten Idee,
mag die Frage aufwerfen,
ob mit Mark noch alles in Ordnung ist.
Aber ich würde behaupten,
gerade bei ihm, gerade bei Meta,
ist dieses Verhalten noch am ehesten nachzuvollziehen.
Im April 2021 passiert etwas,
dass Facebook den Boden unter den Füßen wegreißt.
Ihn unmissverständlich klar macht,
wer die Zügel in der Tech-Branche in Händen hält.
Das iOS-Privacy-Update sorgt dafür,
dass Nutzer von iPhones und iPads
fortan durch ein kleines Banner gefragt werden,
ob ihre Nutzerdaten an die gerade geöffnete App
übermittelt werden sollen oder nicht.
Das Problem für Facebook hierbei,
abzulehnen ist im Gegensatz zu einem Cookie-Banner
genauso leicht wie anzunehmen.
Und Facebooks Geschäftsmodell basiert nun mal fast ausschließlich
auf das Verteilen von Werbeanzeigen auf Basis von Nutzerdaten.
Über Nacht ist Facebook also urplötzlich
bei einem Großteil seiner Zugriffsgeräte blind
und dementsprechend in seiner Effektivität
stark eingeschränkt.
Und dieser Schock, diese verlorene Machtdemonstration,
drängt den Konzern in eine Ecke.
Alles, was bleibt, ist eine Umgebung selbst zu entwickeln,
in der man alle Zügel in Händen hält.
Oder wie Zuckerberg es letzten Monat
im Investoren-Pod gesagt hat,
man kann neue und innovative Dinge entwickeln,
wenn man mehr von allem selbst kontrolliert.
Und nichts anderes ist das Metaverse,
ein Ort, an dem alle drei Variablen
einem einzigen Konzern gehören.
Nicht nur ist Meta...
Ich hoffe, es gibt die neue EA-App,
dann auch im Metaverse.
... in dem Sammeln und Auswerten von Verhaltensdaten,
es hat auch noch Obrigkeit darüber,
wie und was im Metaverse bezahlt wird
und was das Metaverse eigentlich beinhaltet.
Es ist nicht zwangsläufig überzeugend,
die Befürchtung von einem Konzept,
die diesen neuen Unternehmenskurs antreibt,
wie auch.
Es scheint ja kaum eins zu geben.
Es ist eher die Befürchtung,
dass nichts anderes das eigene Unternehmen
vor der virtuellen Bedeutungslosigkeit retten kann.
Und das erklärt, warum ausschließlich hochrangige
Meta-Angestellte Begeisterung für diese Idee...
Tja, da habe ich mich ja schon drüber ausgelassen.
Das sind dann die, die ihren Entwicklern erzählen,
du musst halt an unsere Vision glauben.
Und dann fragen die ja, welche Vision?
Das können sie ihnen auch nicht sagen.
Laut internen Dokumenten des Vice President of Metaverse
nutzen selbst die Leute...
Ja, das kennen wir schon.
Da habe ich jetzt schon öfters was zugesagt.
... um das Metaverse zu entwickeln, das Produkt kaum.
Es heißt, es würde große Qualitäts-
und Performance-Probleme geben.
Und trotz allem hätte Horizon Worlds
noch keinen Beweis für eine Marktauglichkeit erbracht.
Vielleicht braucht den Scheiß einfach auch keiner.
... dass sich die Leute da draußen
für das Metaverse interessieren werden,
wenn es nicht mal ihre Schöpfer können.
In einer Memo an seine Angestellten schreibt er,
sie sollen es sich zur Aufgabe machen,
sich in das Metaverse zu verlieben.
Den Post haben wir schon angekostet.
Du hast jetzt Spaß oder es gibt Ärger.
Und auch außerhalb der Belegschaft
von Metas Milliardenloch gibt es nur...
Eigentlich an der Stelle,
das ist was, was vielen Managern ja irgendwie abgeht,
an dieser Stelle müsste man sich jetzt eigentlich fragen,
wo liegt denn eigentlich das Problem?
Ist das Problem wirklich die Entwickler
oder meine Vision?
Also woran hängt es?
An der Vision oder dass meine Entwickler keinen Bock haben?
Und da müsste er sich an der Stelle wahrscheinlich eingestehen,
da meine Vision ist vielleicht nicht so das,
was die Welt gebraucht hat.
Aber das geht ja nicht.
Begeisterung. Aktuell hat Horizon Worlds
nach Angaben des Unternehmens
knapp 200.000 monatlich aktive Nutzer.
Ach, das kann man schon benutzen?
0,005% von den 3,7...
Das kann man schon benutzen?
Und warum sollte man das benutzen?
7 Milliarden...
Wie viel hat denn...
Steam Charts VR Chat.
So viel haben die nicht, aber...
Wie sieht denn das so aus?
Naja, ziemlich steady, oder?
Ziemlich...
Ist im Prinzip immer mehr geworden hier.
Immer konstant mehr.
Eigentlich eines der wenigen Spiele,
die ich so einen Graph,
wo ich so einen Graph hier gesehen habe.
Normalerweise ist es eher Peak by Release,
wo man sich dann unter und vielleicht zwischen...
Aber hier ist es selten, so einen Graph zu sehen.
...Nutzern auf Metas übrigen Plattformen.
Zum Vergleich, Second Life,
das Metaversum von 2003 sozusagen,
hat auch 200.000 Nutzer.
Das spielt noch jemand.
Und diese internationale Zurückhaltung
in Bezug auf diese virtuelle Parallelwelt
ist auch ziemlich verständlich.
Kaum etwas in Metas oder anderen kleineren Projekten
hat bisher den Eindruck erweckt,
dass hier etwas mit Substanz und Mehrwert entsteht.
Aktuelle Metaverse-Projekte sind geplagt von technischen Fehlern,
stark veralteter Grafik und sozialen Problemen,
verursacht durch einen Mangel an effektiven Konsequenzen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich meine, dieses Bild, warum man das gepostet hat,
das kann ja wirklich nur realitätsferner kann man nicht sein.
Irgendwelche Billig-Assets da rein importiert.
Und drumherum ist halt nichts.
Was soll uns das sagen überhaupt?
Und schon jetzt sind diese Projekte stark und schonungslos durchmacht.
Warum das auch?
Ich verstehe übrigens auch nicht, warum das so teuer ist.
... Club von Metas Horizon Worlds applaudieren will,
der muss dafür mit echtem Geld zahlen.
Und wir haben noch nicht mal über die illusorischen Versprechungen
von NFTs gesprochen.
Es ist für mich wirklich schwer,
mich in einen der wenigen Menschen hineinzuversetzen,
der ehrliche Vorfreude für das Metaverse empfindet.
Klar, es könnte so sein, wie Mokitown damals für mich war,
nur halt in VR und globaler und mit der Möglichkeit,
Lukas Rieger seine NFTs ausstellen kann.
Aber eine über die Realität gestülpte virtuelle Parallelwelt,
die in den Händen eines der furchtbarsten Unternehmen der Welt ist,
es gibt optimistischere Dystopien.
Die Idee, einfach alles virtuell nachzustellen,
kommt zudem zu einem Zeitpunkt, an dem immer mehr Leute
ihre eigene Zeit am Bildschirm und im Internet bewusst verringern.
Ist das so?
Und das Metaverse wird in dieser Form nur als Monopol funktionieren.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass wir die echte Welt doch gar nicht im Spiel haben.
Echte Wellen habe ich doch genug.
Soziale Implikationen, Promovideos, der ganze bisherige Sinn...
Ich will irgendeine Mittelalter-Fantasy-Welt haben oder so was,
aber ich will doch nicht Frankfurt mir dann virtuell angucken.
Das reicht mir in echt schon.
... die sich dafür ernsthaft interessieren werden.
Und ein Monopol wäre zwar schlecht,
aber es ist auch genauso unwahrscheinlich.
Wenn es ein Metaverse irgendwann mal zu Erfolg schafft,
dann werden es gleich mehrere tun.
Im Endeffekt, dank fehlendem Monopol
wird es auch keine neue Welt geben,
in der man soziale Außergewöhnlichkeit erreichen kann.
Denn es wird immer den einen Kollegen geben,
der lieber das andere Metaverse nutzt,
um Low-Poly-Business-Meetings am Pixel-Strand abzuhalten.
Erst war ich traurig,
aber mittlerweile bin ich, glaube ich, ganz glücklich darüber,
dass es Mokitown nicht mehr gibt,
dass es kaum noch Bildmaterial davon gibt,
meine Erinnerungen daran hauptsächlich aus nostalgischen Gefühlen bestehen
und ich keine Chancen mehr habe.
Also ich werde...
im Dezember wieder Dark auf dem Freeshot spielen.
Soviel kann ich euch schon mal sagen.
Ich mach jeden neuen Freeshot mit für ein paar Monate.
Einfach immer noch bestes MMO.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
wenn nicht nur meine Freunde,
sondern wirklich jeder damals in Mokitown gewesen wäre,
dann hätte ich vermutlich gar keine Erinnerungen mehr daran.
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel virtuell...
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel ist wie gesagt in echt schon kacke.
Man weiß nicht, warum ich da virtuell hingehen sollte.
Die erste Nuke in Warzone 2.
Gibt's ne Nuke?
Ach ja, das ist diese Geschichte mit wenn du...
wenn du 5 Games gewonnen hast und dann irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie 5er Winstreak und dann musst du noch irgendwas machen.
Haben wir uns heute von Level Cap chibaten lassen?
Nein, wir haben uns noch nicht von Level Cap chibaten lassen,
aber da gab's auch nix.
Gibt nix, was Level Cap uns chibaten kann.
No Pass.
Kein Level Cap chibaten.
Kein Level Cap chibaten heute.
Fuck, an der Haustür.
Overwatch 2 is a new low in gaming.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir Overwatch 2 angucken will.
Battlefield 1 ist zurück und geht gerade richtig ab.
Ja, das hab ich mitbekommen.
Hat mich auch sehr verwundert.
Hier ist Steam Charts.
Was macht...
Okay, eine Sache muss ich die üblichen verdächtigen.
Lass mal kurz schauen.
Also New World, ihr werdet's nicht glauben, Leute.
New World hat relativ viele Spiele aktuell.
Aber das liegt nicht daran, dass sie irgendwie super krasses Zeug gemacht haben.
Also viele, ja.
Immerhin.
Die haben einfach quasi so eine Art neue Season gestartet.
Die haben neue Server rausgebracht.
Und das ist generell das Beste, was du als MMO machen kannst.
Neustarts regelmäßig.
Die Leute mögen einfach neue Server, neue Charaktere, Crimen und alles.
Okay.
2042 ist mal wieder ziemlich im Arsch.
Aber in zwei Tagen geht die neue Season online.
Das werden wir uns auf jeden Fall angucken.
Und was macht denn Steam Charts?
Steam Charts Battlefield 1.
Lull.
Ha!
Geil.
Guck mal.
28.000 Leute, 24 Stunden Peak versus 5000.
Da liegen einfach irgendwie fünf Jahre oder so zwischen den Games und das ist das Neueste.
Tja.
Es ist halt auch ein gescheites Game.
Im Vergleich zu 2042.
Halt ein Game mit Detail und Liebe gemacht und nicht so ein hingeklatschter Crap.
Was möchte YouTube eigentlich von uns?
Möchte YouTube eigentlich von uns da oben?
Achso.
Weil Fußball heute.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Weißt du, die Leute sagen so nach dem Motto.
Ja, WM in Katar muss man boykottieren.
Und ich denke mir so.
Ich habe noch nie großartig WM geguckt.
Generell Fußball geguckt.
Ich muss da nichts boykottieren.
Ich hätte das auch so nicht geguckt.
Ubisoft in Flammen.
Warum ist Ubisoft in Flammen?
Ubisoft entwickelt, aber haben...
Okay.
Ist das von Maurice?
Mal gucken von wem das ist.
Maurice gucke ich immer gern.
Aber das streamt ja hauptsächlich.
... ist einer der größten Publisher auf dem Spielemarkt und hat besonders...
Es ist...
Dings hier.
Den.
Den...
Die Stimme kenne ich.
Wer ist denn das?
Von denen.
... das mit seinen Open World Serien ganze Genre geprägt.
Das ist nicht Dimitri, das ist der Andere.
Das ist der...
Der...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Das Unternehmen hatte über Jahre hinweg immer wieder Überraschungen im Großen und Kleinen.
Probierte mit kleinen Marken wie Valiant Hearts oder Child of Light neue Gameplay-Konzepte
aus.
Steht aber natürlich auch für große Namen wie...
Fritz?
Ja, das ist Fritz.
Genau, Chad.
Ihr habt Recht.
... Far Cry und Assassin's Creed.
Ubisoft erschuf Marken, die von Millionen Spielern geliebt, heiß diskutiert und vor allem
gespielt wurden.
Doch in den letzten Jahren sorgte der Konzern auch mit Sexismus-Skandalen für Schlagzeilen
und enttäuschte...
Mittlerweile ist es ja fast so...
Sagt mir mal einen großen Publisher, wo es doch keinen Sexismus-Skandal gab.
Das ist ja wirklich der Wahnsinn mittlerweile.
Gut, ich mein Blizzard hat es wie immer, wenn man wieder von allen auf die Spitze geht.
Oder Activision Blizzard.
... mit zu viel Formelarbeit und zu wenig...
Wir haben es wieder übertrieben.
... und Ubisoft produzierte auch einige Rohrkrepierer.
Mal verrannte man sich beim Versuch...
Stimmt.
... auf aktuelle Spiele...
Hey, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie das hieß.
Dieses Ubisoft Battle Royale.
Scape?
Escape?
Wie hieß das nochmal?
Scape?
Irgendwas mit Scape?
Wie hieß das?
Moment, Moment.
Ubisoft.
Hyperscape.
Genau.
Gibt es das noch?
Da steht unten links.
Ah ja, steht unten links.
Lul.
Äh.
Hyperscape.
Kacke.
Und ist das Spiel down?
Ach, das wurde eingestellt.
Das ist komplett eingestellt.
Okay.
... aufzuspringen, dann zogen sich die Entwickler auf die Bühne.
Und...
Dann zogen sich die Entwicklungen anderer Projekte teilweise ewig in die Länge.
Und wiederum andere Spiele haben es nicht mal bis zum Release geschafft oder wurden vorher
noch stark umgebaut.
Wir haben mal versucht, uns einen Überblick zu den aktuellen Sorgenkindern von Ubisoft
zu verschaffen und sind bei einer erschreckend langen Liste rausgekommen.
Ubisoft-Spiele.
Du brauchst Türme, die du erobern kannst.
Du brauchst irgendwelche riesigen Maps, gefüllt mit Kisten und unsinnigen Sachen.
Also die Ubisoft-Spiele sind schon sehr ähnlich.
Aber Türme.
Türme ist das Allerwichtigste.
... die komplett eingestellten Spiele.
Die Spiele, die wohl große Probleme in der Entwicklung haben.
Und...
Türme.
... die tatsächlich rausgekommen...
Was macht eigentlich das neue Siedler?
Sollte da nicht ein neues Siedler sogar kommen?
Irgendwann die letzten Jahre über?
Und kam glaube ich bis heute nicht.
... auch gleich wieder untergegangen sind.
Fangen wir mit den eingestellten Spielen an.
Vor über einem Jahr kündigte Ubisoft mit Ghost Recon Frontline einen neuen Free-to-Play-Shooter
an.
Irgendwo zwischen Battle Royale und klassischem Arena-Shooter wollte man die Marke nach dem
Open-World-Sprung von Wildlands und dem Loot-Shooter Breakpoint...
Habe ich für Breakpoint nicht sogar Werbung gemacht?
Oh, ich habe für Breakpoint Werbung gemacht.
Ja.
... nun für ein noch größeres Publikum öffnen, nämlich die Battle-Royale-Crowd.
Geplant war zum einen...
Was kann da schon schiefgehen?
... einen Spielmodus mit 102 Spielern, die in Teams von je drei Leuten...
Okay, 102 wahrscheinlich, weil es schon ein anderes Game gab, das 101 Spieler hatte
und man wollte sagen, das größte Battle Royale aller Zeiten.
... Treffen sowie eine kleinere 9 gegen 9 Spielvariante.
Das Ganze sollte stetig ausgebaut werden und regelmäßig...
Das sieht so langweilig schon aus.
... Updates in Form von Seasons bekommen, ähnlich wie in Fortnite und Co.
Im Sommer 2022 gab die Führungsetat...
... von Ubisoft jedoch in einem Quartalsbericht bekannt, dass die Entwicklung komplett eingestellt wurde.
Das sieht so uninspiriert und langweilig aus.
... war aber auch nicht gerade gutes Feedback durchgesickert.
Die derzeit unsichere wirtschaftliche Lage habe es dann laut Ubisoft erfordert,
die Entwicklungskräfte auf andere Projekte zu bündeln.
Frontline war damit Geschichte.
Im gleichen Quartalsbericht...
Ich frage mich immer, wie das als Entwickler sein muss.
Wenn man wirklich mal als Entwickler echt an einem Spiel arbeitet und mitgestalten kann,
vielleicht was man persönlich super findet und irgendwie sich da...
Also wenn man das halt so machen kann, wie ich am Anfang mal gesagt habe,
bei einem der letzten Videos hier.
Wenn man dann wirklich mal ein Spiel machen kann, was man selbst gerne spielen will.
Mal angenommen, man ist da wirklich ein bisschen investiert und sieht es nicht so rein als...
Ja, ich mache halt das, was irgendein Typ sich ausgedacht hat.
Ich kriege da halt mein Geld für.
Ich frage mich, wie das ist.
Wenn dann einfach das Game, an dem du dann irgendwie drei Jahre gearbeitet hast, eingestellt wird.
Das ist bestimmt auch kein allzu tolles Gefühl.
So nach dem Motto, ja, drei Jahre umsonst.
... sägte Ubisoft auch eine VR-Umsetzung von Splinter Cell ab.
Die befand sich seit 2020 in der Entwicklung und sollte exklusiv für die VR-Brillen des Facebook-Konzerns Meta erscheinen.
Videomaterial gab es zu diesem Projekt noch genauso wenig wie eine klare Gameplay-Beschreibung.
Scheinbar wusste Ubisoft das nicht.
Und Ubisoft mal wieder nicht so richtig, was sie mit 10 Fischer anfangen sollten.
Das hat ja leider seit Jahren Tradition.
Und jeder neue Auftritt des Agenten in irgendeinem Mobile-Ableger wird nur noch entkräftet belächelt.
Frontline und Splinter Cell VR waren aber nicht die einzigen eingestellten Spiele.
Im selben Quartalsbericht wurde auch bekannt gegeben, dass zwei bisher unbekannter Titel ebenfalls auf Eis liegen.
Über die beiden Spiele sind bislang keine Informationen an die Öffentlichkeit gedrungen.
Aber das kann sich in den nächsten Jahren ja noch ändern.
Die Games sehen alle so langweilig und 0815 aus.
Das Video wird euch präsentiert von den GameStar-PCs in Kooperation mit Boostbox.
Die GameStar-PCs wurden in den letzten Jahren aber mit vielen Problemen unveröffentlicht.
Oh, das war ein viel kürzeres Placement, als ich gedacht habe.
Kommen wir zu den noch unveröffentlichten Spielen, die tatsächlich immer noch in der Mache sind, in den letzten Jahren aber mit vielen Problemen zu kämpfen hatten.
Und wenn ihr das nicht wisst, dann wisst ihr, was wir hier sagen.
Und welches Spiel passt auf diese Beschreibung besser als Skull & Bones?
Das eigentlich endlich 2022 rauskommen sollte und nun wieder verschoben wurde.
Diesmal auf März 2023.
Das wurde vor, ich kann nicht sagen, das wurde doch schon vor Ewigkeiten angekündigt.
In über fünf Jahren werkelt Ubisoft Singapur schon an der Freibeuter-Simulation mit Multiplayer-Fokus.
Gab's da nicht sogar mal eine Beta zwischendurch?
Oder war das was anderes?
Schiffskampf aus Assassin's Creed 4.
Und was ist mit den Phänomenenkugeln in einer Open World um die Segelmasten ballern?
Aber schon die vielen Verschiebungen seit der ersten Ankündigung deuten darauf hin, dass der Kutter schon mehrmals zu kentern drohte.
Berichten zufolge durchlief Skull & Bones bereits mehrere Reboots, weil das Entwicklerteam selbst immer wieder Konzepte verwarf.
Hinzu kommen Probleme mit der staatlichen Förderung in Singapur.
Ubisoft erhält zwar finanzielle Unterstützung, muss dafür aber auch bestimmte Deadlines einhalten
und kann andererseits auch nicht einfach das ganze Projekt einstampfen.
Skull & Bones muss also rauskommen.
Dabei sorgt das Spiel bislang vor allem für Skepsis.
Die Gameplay-Mechaniken wirken schlicht zu dünn für ein langfristig motivierendes Erlebnis,
das sowohl solo als auch im Koop und im PvP funktionieren soll.
Wahrscheinlich hat man sich schlicht und ergreifend total übernommen.
Und nachdem die Segelmassen, die eigentlich für November gesetzt waren, verschob Ubisoft Skull & Bones kürzlich dann nochmal um mehrere Monate.
als Duke Nukem Forever.
Dieser traurige Rekord dürfte aber eines der...
Aber nicht länger als Half-Life 3.
...geringsten Probleme des Spiels sein.
Erstmals 2008 angekündigt,
waren Infos zu Beyond Good & Evil 2 lange Zeit rar gesehen.
Auf der E3 2017 tauchte es dann aber plötzlich wieder auf
und überraschte mit äußerst ambitionierten Plänen.
Im Gegensatz zum Vorgänger soll Teil 2...
Okay, das heißt, sie haben nichts dafür gemacht,
außer einen Render-Trailer erstellen.
...eine vorartige Welt bieten,
die uns komplette Sonnensysteme zum Erkunden eröffnet,
inklusive Landungen auf Planeten
und prozedural erstellte Megastädte.
Okay, und was hat man davon gesehen?
Einen Render-Trailer.
Schafft immer sehr großes Vertrauen da drin.
Dann scheint die Diagnose einfach.
Ubisoft hat sich schlicht übernommen.
Seit 2019 gab es zwar immer wieder mal kleine Lebenszeichen vom Spiel,
offizielle Infos, was nun Sache ist, fehlen aber.
Laut Gerüchten soll Beyond Good & Evil 2
aber mittlerweile ganz anders aussehen.
Aber immer noch weit von einer Fertigstellung entfernt sein.
Einer der bekanntesten Schöpfer des Originals,
Michel Arcel, hat Ubisoft schon von der ganzen Weile verlassen.
Ob Beyond Good & Evil 2 tatsächlich noch rauskommt,
steht also da, wo das Spiel hin will, in den Sternen.
So richtig schlau sind wir aus Avatar Frontiers of Pandora
bisher noch nicht geworden.
Daher kam auch die Release-Verschiebung im Juli 2022 nicht mehr.
Wer hat bitteschön auf den Avatar,
und wie lange hat sich das Game gewartet?
Besonders überraschend.
Bis dahin gab es nämlich nur einen vollwertigen Trailer
in vermeintlicher Spielgrafik,
der aber eigentlich nicht viel über das Spiel verriet.
Mal abgesehen vom Setting, der Ego-Perspektive
und, dass wir auf Seiten der Navi spielen,
also der Bewohner von Pandora.
Okay, ich mein, es passt eigentlich ganz gut,
wollte ich grad sagen, es passt ganz gut,
weil es ja irgendwie demnächst mal wieder einen Film gibt.
Die sich gegen die Ausbeutung durch die Menschen wehren.
Das sah zwar dank Snowdrop-Energy,
die wir ja aus The Division kennen, bildhübsch aus,
aber was man in der Open World als blaues Alien alles tun kann,
blieb bisher größtenteils offen.
Wie interagieren Flora und Fauna miteinander?
Was für eine Story wird hier erzählt?
Wie sieht das Progressionssystem aus?
Keine Ahnung.
Kein Wunder also, dass Ubisoft das Spiel vom Entwicklerteam Massive
auf einen unbestimmten Termin zwischen 2023 und 2024 verschoben hat.
Läuft ja wirklich gut bei Ubisoft.
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Diese Release-Verschiebung ist natürlich auch...
Aber ich wollte grad sagen, was macht man?
Du, ohne Scheiß, Schreiker, ich wollte grad ähnlich was Ähnliches sagen.
Wahrscheinlich wirst du Türme erobern.
Ich finde das bitter, weil im Dezember ja auch ein neuer Avatar-Film ins Kino kommt
und sich so eine tolle Synergie ergeben hätte.
Hoffen wir, dass Frontiers of Pandora durch die zusätzliche Entwicklungszeit
mehr wird als eine zugegebenermaßen wunderschöne Tech-Demo
oder das nächste 0815 Open World Spiel,
bei dem wir eigentlich nur eine von Missionssymbolen-Folge
knallte Karte mit formellem 2-2-Aufgabe dabei haben.
Und Türme! Und Türme! Türme! Ganz wichtig, das Ubisoft!
Ein weiteres Sorgenkind bei Ubisoft ist das Remake von Prince of Persia The Sands of Time.
Da kam schon der erste Trailer...
Ach, das soll remaked werden?
Die Neuauflage wirkte besonders bei der Grafik stellenweise völlig veraltet.
Egal ob Charaktermodelle, Animationen oder Texturen,
alles schien mindestens zwei Klassen unter dem sonstigen Ubisoft-Standard.
Laut anonymen Quellen hatten die beiden noch vergleichsweise unerfahrene,
indischen Entwickler-Studios von Ubisoft auch zu wenig Unterstützung von anderen Teams bekommen.
Das negative Feedback auf den ersten Trailer und die Probleme in der Entwicklung
führten gleich zu mehreren Verschiebungen.
Inzwischen gibt es gar keinen neuen Termin für das Spiel,
das aber laut den Stimulierungen tatsächlich noch in Entwicklung ist.
Ubisoft Montreal, das Studio hinter dem 2003er Original,
hat nun die Leitung des Projekts übernommen.
Ob damit aber eine Veröffentlichung im nächsten Jahr gesichert ist, wissen wir nicht.
Ubisoft hat aber schon gesagt, dass die anderen Serienteile vorerst keine Neuauflage bekommen sollen.
Die Siedlerei befindet sich schon länger in einer Identitätskrise.
Die hatten doch schon vor drei Jahren oder so Neues gezeigt, aber das gab's dann nie.
Frühere Ableger schwanken zwischen den Genres und mussten sich immer wieder neu erfinden.
Während sich die ersten Spiele der Serie der klassischen Aufbaustrategie,
Echtzeitstrategie verschrieben, kamen später Echtzeitstrategie-Elemente dazu.
Ja, ab dem Dreier konntest du ja dann deine Soldaten und konntest du ja steuern.
Ähm, Siedler 2 hab ich damals wirklich rauf und runter gespielt.
Und auch das letzte war gar nicht so schlecht.
Das war zwar recht anders, was war denn das? War das Siedler 7? Nee.
Oder? Oder 6?
Nee.
Äh, 8? Ich glaube, ich mein 7.
Ja, das war das doch. Das war gar nicht übel.
Das hat schon Spaß gemacht.
Aus den Überresten des gescheiterten Die Siedler 7 bastelte Entwickler Bluebyte sogar mit Champions League.
Dann war's nicht 7, dann war's 6?
Ich weiß es nicht. Das mit dem weiblichen Protagonistin, ja?
Oder was war das, Siedler?
Ähm...
Ach, keine Ahnung, welches das war.
Das war nicht übel.
Das hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Also die Kampagne.
Alles hab ich da nie gespielt.
Seit wann ich auf Twitch bin? Schon lange.
... Champions of Anteria, einen halbgaren Rollenspiel-ATX-Mix.
Mit Teil 8 wollte man dann wieder zurück zum Ursprung, so richtig mit gemächlichem Spieltempo und detailreicher Darstellung von Produktionszyklen.
In der Theorie eine gute Idee, doch irgendwas ging während der Entwicklung schief.
Der Release wurde von 2019 auf 2020 und dann auf eine unbestimmte Zeit verschoben.
Ah, okay, so sieht's da also aus.
Na toll.
Und weil immer die Siedler Entwicklungsprobleme haben, scheinen die Verantwortlichen schnell bei einer Lösung zu sein.
Wie wäre es mit ein bisschen Echtzeitstrategie?
Anfang 2022 tauchte das Spiel jedenfalls in einer spielbaren Beta wieder auf.
Also ich finde, das hat null Siedler-Style, die Grafik.
Die stieß allerdings sofort bei Fans und Presse auf reichlich Kritik.
Das Gameplay war schlicht zu hemmsärmlich, gerade im Vergleich zur internationalen Konkurrenz.
Schon nach wenigen Partien verpuffte jedwede Varianz und endete in Gleichförmigkeit.
Ubisoft hörte...
Na mal ganz im Ernst, also ich will den Kram doch auch nicht wegen Multiplayer spielen.
Also ich meine, es ist cool.
Also am besten, am meisten Bock hat mir damals immer noch gemacht, wenn man Multiplayer gespielt hat, Siedler 2.
Weil das wird heute wahrscheinlich keiner mehr, kann sich da wahrscheinlich keiner mehr reinversetzen.
Aber was mir mega Bock gemacht hat damals, war Siedler 2, Splitscreen mit zwei Mäusen am gleichen PC.
Das waren Sachen, die haben Games damals unterstützt.
Du konntest quasi mit zwei Spielern am PC spielen, Splitscreen mit zwei Mäusen.
Das war mega nice.
Also halt gegen NPCs, ja.
...masche Kritik und rückte erstmal von einer Veröffentlichung im Jahr 2022 ab.
Seit der Beta-Katastrophe versucht das Entwicklerteam nun, am RTS-Konzept zu feilen.
Aus der einst geplanten...
Anno ist auch von Ubisoft.
Ja, mittlerweile.
...Rückkehr wird aber wohl nichts mehr.
Ursprünglich war Anno, glaube ich mal, wie hieß er, die Sunflower Games oder so?
Sunflowers?
Ja.
Das waren mal nur die Ursprünge.
Mittlerweile ist das aber alles Ubisoft.
Und dann gibt es ja auch noch X-Defiant.
Ein Free-to-Play-Shooter...
Was für ein Ding?
...der schon nach der ersten Ankündigung 2021 viel Kritik kassierte.
Habe ich nicht voll mitbekommen.
Zubekannt und altmodisch schien für viele die Formel aus Arena-Shooter, Klassenfähigkeiten und...
Zwei Mäuse an einem PC, ja.
Du konntest damals, das war eigentlich wirklich nice, Siedler 2, Splitscreen...
Zwei Mäuse, ja, genau.
So sah das dann aus.
Du musstest zwei Mäuse anschließen, serieller Port, nicht USB, Leute.
Serial Port, please, ja.
Serial Port, zwei Mäuse.
Und dann konnte einer auf der linken Seite spielen und einer auf der rechten Seite spielen.
Und das damals...
Das damals natürlich auf irgendeinem kleinen CRT, also 1024x768, wenn es hochkam.
Ja.
So sah das aus.
Das ist aber deutlich mehr, als man damals gesehen hat.
Irgendwie hätte ich übelst Bock drauf.
Mal wieder.
Wisst ihr?
Das ist auch eines der coolen Sachen an Pixel-Grafik.
So Pixel-Grafik veraltet irgendwie nicht richtig.
Das sieht immer noch ganz brauchbar aus.
Oh Mann, ja.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel.
Und das war schwer.
Also die Kampagne war damals, also fand ich damals, wirklich schwer.
...Style für möglichst diverse Skins, die man später als Mikrotransaktionen verkaufen kann.
Noch dazu trug der flippige Shooter den Namen Tom Clancy.
Weil hier verschiedene Fraktionen aus Ubisofts Clancy-Universum aufeinandertreffen.
Mittlerweile heißt ja bei denen alles Tom Clancy.
Der Typ hat ja die Namensrechte verkauft vor 20 Jahren oder so.
Seitdem gibt es ja da alles.
Tom Clancies Sofa, Tom Clancies Klo, Tom Clancies Ghost Streaking, Tom Clancies Warfighter, Tom Clancies...
Also es ist alles Tom Clancy.
Das missfiel besonders den Splinters...
Tom Clancies Anno 1800.
...Fans, die seit Jahren keine richtige Fortsetzung bekommen, sondern nur halbgare Referenzen.
Die Folge? Auf zahlreichen Social-Media-Kanälen regnete es negative Kommentare.
Und scheinbar ist auch Ubisoft aufgefallen, dass der Name des verstorbenen US-Autors hier nicht unbedingt angebracht ist.
Vor ein paar Monaten verschwand der Zusatz Tom Clancy jedenfalls von allen Werbeauftritten.
Seitdem heißt das Spiel nicht mehr Tom Clancy.
Nicht mehr Tom Clancies X-Defiant, sondern einfach nur noch X-Defiant.
Wie es um das Spiel selbst steht, lässt sich derzeit aber nicht wirklich einschätzen.
Man kann sich zwar für geschlossene Testläufe registrieren.
Eine öffentliche Beta wird es aber wahrscheinlich frühestens 2023 geben, falls das Projekt überhaupt noch final umgesetzt wird.
Ubisoft müsste jedenfalls einen...
Wisst ihr, was bei solchen Gameplays immer witzig ist, wenn ich das sehe?
...aber wahrscheinlich frühestens 2023 geben...
Da siehst du halt, dass das gescriptet ist.
Der Dude weiß halt jetzt...
Der aimt da hin, ja?
Der weiß jetzt... Ah, der läuft da genau rein.
Hm, zufälligerweise laufen die immer den gleichen Weg.
...umgesetzt wird.
Ubisoft müsste jedenfalls einen deutlich besseren zweiten Eindruck mit dem Spiel machen.
Weil das ist ja das eigentliche Schwierige an Headshots, wenn die Gegner normal moven.
Da musst du nicht nur predikten, wo die hinlaufen, sondern musst im Zweifelsfall das auch noch ein bisschen korrigieren.
Wenn der Shooter zum Erfolg werden soll.
Und schnell sein. Und genau sein.
Und damit sind wir bei den Flops, die Ubisoft in letzter Zeit produziert und auch veröffentlicht hat.
Anthem. Moment, sorry, Anthem war nicht Ubisoft.
Da hätten wir zum einen Hyperscape.
Das war ja...
Das war ein Battle-Royale-Shooter, der 2020 im umkämpften Genre eine eigene Präsenz aufbauen wollte.
Aber das hat augenscheinlich nicht funktioniert.
Die waren viel zu spät. Die waren viel zu spät und irgendwie hat mich das Spiel auch null angesprochen.
Da waren die Server so leer, dass Ubisoft die Reißleine zog.
Hyperscape hob sich von der Konkurrenz vor allem durch zwei Aspekte ab.
Zum einen betonte das futuristische Level-Design eine vertikale Vorgehensweise, die flotte Matches provozieren sollte.
Zum anderen legte Ubisoft sehr viel Wert darauf, seine Battle-Royale-Kreation mit Twitch zu vermehlen.
Über die Streaming-Plattform konnten Zuschauer Einfluss auf laufende Partien nehmen.
Oder durchs bloße Anschauen von Hyperscape-Streams ihren Battle-Pass-Leveln.
Trotz der zweifelsohne interessanten Idee ging Hyperscape aber nie richtig viral.
Auch spätere Updates...
Ich glaube, das lag hauptsächlich an dem Game selbst.
...die nochmal das Gameplay überarbeiten wollten, konnten nicht den erhofften Effekt erzielen.
Im April 2022 wurde das Spiel eingestellt.
Während Hyperscape der Battle-Royale-Formel hinterherhechtete,
war bei Roller Champions der Erfolg von Rocket League...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ist das irgendein Rocket League-Clone?
Hier jagen wir auf Rollerblades quer durch eine ovalförmige Arena...
Von diesem Spiel habe ich seriously noch nie was gehört.
...versuchen, einen Ball in ein Tor zu werfen.
Simples, aber vielversprechendes Spielkonzept mit Potenzial für langfristige Umsätze.
Zumindest in der Theorie.
Die ersten Reaktionen auf das Free-to-Play-Spiel waren auch recht wohlwollend.
Doch schon kurz nach der Veröffentlichung im Mai 2022,
verschwand Roller Champions in der Bedeutungslosigkeit.
Offizielle Spielerzahlen sind zwar nicht bekannt,
aber auf Twitch bewegen sich die durchschnittlichen Zuschauerzahlen in den letzten Monaten zwischen 70 und 120...
Boah, das ist ja nix!
... kein gutes Zeichen für ein Service-Spiel.
Im Sommer berichtete außerdem ein vermeintlicher Insider,
dass Ubisoft äußerst unzufrieden wegen des ausbleibenden Erfolgs von Roller Champions sei.
Sogar eine Einstellung des Projekts sei möglich, hieß es da.
Ubisoft selbst dementierte allerdings die Gerüchte und beteuerte, dass man weiter am Spiel arbeiten will.
Erst Anfang Oktober erschien mit Weg des Drachen eine neue Saison mit neuen Karten und weiteren Verbesserungen.
Das spricht mich auch nicht wirklich an, ehrlich gesagt.
Noch hat Roller Champions also durchaus die Chance, ähnlich wie Rainbow Six Siege, zu einem Hit zu reifen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Wenn auch im deutlich kleineren Rahmen. Also wenn überhaupt.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und das war's. Ein kleiner Überblick über die aktuellen oder auch schon abgeschlossenen Problemprojekte von Ubisoft.
Ein paar Namen, wie das Remake von Splinter Cell oder auch das neue The Division,
was ja ein Free-to-Play-Ableger werden wird, sind jetzt hier nicht mit dabei,
weil da noch nicht wirklich klar ist, wie laufen die Projekte rund.
Wird es da Probleme geben? Also haben wir sie eher rausgelassen.
Läuft bei Ubisoft.
Aber ihr könnt ja gerne mal in den Kommentaren schreiben, welchen von diesen Spielen ihr vielleicht nachweint,
weil sie nicht umgesetzt wurden.
Ehrlich gesagt, keinem.
Weil sie vielleicht eingestellt wurden.
Wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Lass dich uns wissen.
Nicht wirklich.
Keinem.
Oh, ich habe Hunger, Leute.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Pepo-Fett mache ich jetzt.
Eine Nook ist das.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendjemanden hosten können.
Wir könnten den Lost hosten.
Was macht der denn?
Warzone, MonkaS.
Nee, Warzone brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Host gibt es noch, klar.
Oder Raids.
Ja, Host, Raids.
Alles aufs Gleiche raus.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich gehe jetzt einfach auf.
Gehst du heute noch spazieren?
Weiß ich nicht.
Scheiß Wetter und es ist Sonntag.
Aber vielleicht, vielleicht.
Wie gesagt, sonntags bin ich ja meistens nicht so aktiv.
Dafür jeden anderen Tag.
Ich kann Wobblos hosten.
High IQ.
Gute Idee.
Sollte man machen.
Ich hoste mich selbst.
Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn ich mich selbst hoste?
Das geht nicht, Leute.
Man kann sich nicht selbst hosten.
Raid?
Wobblos?
Du kannst dich nicht selbst raiden, steht da.
Okay.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist ja doof.
Man kann sich nicht selbst raiden.
Ja.
Recursive Raiding.
Alles klar.
Wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis denn.
See you.